good morning welcome to uh Public Works
uh we have a executive session scheduled
for 9:30 I'm going to recess from that
for 10 minutes so the uh two parties can
caucus and we're waiting for an
amendment that doesn't appear to have
arrived for one of our bills so uh we're
going to have a short uh recess here
thank
you
for uh for the members present uh
represent Melvin um won't be with us
today he has a doctor's appointment uh I
would just say to uh to the members of
the
committee if if you have a appointment
that has to reschedule or you have an
appointment if you could let myself or
the vice chair know a full day ahead of
time it's not really an overly big issue
with our committee but a lot of bills
I'd like to pass out out with as many
people as we can so it was too late in
the day for me to uh pull a replacement
I know John does a better job of that so
we will do better next time just one of
the things about the Pledge of
Allegiance yes yes yes who was which
I before we start I'd like to uh if we
could stand for a pledge of allegiance
represent would you please lead us
thank
you
you I want to thank uh representative
Newton for bringing that to my attention
and John we'll make sure we put that on
important we
[Music]
will thank you we will open up the uh
executive
session for uh House Bill 122 FN and
House Bill
1510 uh for some of the uh members that
arrived just a little while ago uh we
had I had expected an amendment to come
through under my name on
122 uh but there's been a mixup at uh
with a drafting and that didn't come
over here this morning there's a new
procedure it goes upstairs comes down to
us and uh so what we are going to do is
we are going to open up um House Bill
first and um then we will will recess
out um our timing issue is that this
bill needs to come out of committee it's
an early Bill uh we're under a schedule
right now of noon so I suspect if I can
get this drafted brought back we'll
probably recess the do
presentation and uh exec the bill at
that time and if we're all fortunate
that'll happen by noon so I would like
to open up the executive session on
House Bill
1510 establishing a commission to
identify barriers and two solutions for
electric vehicle sales and use and I
recognize recognize representative Boyd
for a motion thank you Mr chairman Mr
chairman I would move House Bill 1510 as
inexpedient to
legislate I'll second that a motion made
by Boyd seconded by Mills to uh itl
House Bill 1510 we are are open for
would you like to discuss your motion
represent voy or we'll open it up to the
rest of the representatives yeah I would
prefer you open it up to the rest of
representatives represent Mills um thank
you Mr chair once again first of all
this bill came to us accidentally it
should have gone to Science and Tech it
was never our perview for this second of
all we have
a we have pass we have acted on so many
bills on electric vehicles so far I
believe we have passed the one for our
ongoing commission that can easily
handle easily handle this as an assigned
task and uh for that reason I I don't
feel it's necessary at this time and
seconded the itl thank thank you um
further discussion uh
questions when you say commission I just
want to be clear before we vote is this
the the study commission that we P we
had a bill for House Bill 412 last year
and then we have 1631 this year I just
want to clarify that correct thank
you represent hner thank you Mr chairman
I uh would prefer that we go to an itl I
would say that
this commission isn't ready yet
given other actions taken by other
committees on EVS but I'm very concerned
about the negative image that this
conveys that
certainly it illustrates that one of the
barriers to
implementation is you know this this
legislature
not taking up actions that would in fact
permit or allow or even encourage uh EV
sales charging stations
Etc the state certainly has a
role if only as an employee of people
who drive EVS to work it has potentially
other roles that we could play or at
least to get out of the way I think
there's a a long list of things that uh
should be looked at by somebody now I I
can you know I'm wary of having just
another
commission uh and particularly given how
long it takes to develop these things I
think that itl will allow us to focus
this more perhaps find an
existing group that can have its
assignment changed or even to identify
what the what the barriers are so that
we can develop more um forward-looking
legislation I think this is just going
to be seen as another sort of climate
change
denying uh
anti-progress action if we do itl so
I and strongly urged we not do that and
that we in fact put us out for interim
study thank you representative uh
representative Pon
please oh sorry represent
vone uh thank you Mr chairman so I I
think you did clarify so you're you're
proposing an interim study as opposed to
itl is that that correct we have we have
a different motion on the floor so I
would propose itl if this one fails all
right thanks further yes represent vo uh
thank you Mr chairman I I just want to
not getting a a ping pong with my with
with my good friend representative
vulner but what I would say from from
some of the testimony that fire marshall
Toney talked to about the science on
lithiums have been changing and coming
and um some of the things having served
locally in my community some of the the
challenges that my fire chiefs have
experienced in dealing with with traffic
accidents as it as it relates to to Li
lithium batteries maybe you know once
small snippet of of of of the larger
picture of how EVS are going to have an
impact in our society but the larger
thing that I looked at is several months
ago and I know General Motors is one and
I don't want to throw out another
Corporation and be held in contempt but
I know that there was at least three
Motor companies that were scaling back
their electric vehicle production um
forecast for this particular year and
next the next particular year which I I
think cuts into the testimony that uh M
Willcox from D has provided as it
relates to the iso forecast so um I'm
not I'm not a denier I think I think
electric vehicles are here to stay I
think they are a part of the I think
they are a part of the future um but how
we choose to um
address what we do as a state as it
relates to to EVS I I actually think
that s
sp430 um is is doing that I think think
is having that conversation and then if
there's a need to have a larger
conversation we can build off of that so
uh I I would prefer I would I want I
want to try and look at this
incrementally um which is why I think
itl is is the right motion at this at
this particular stage of the game
further further yes please say I think
that everything you said and certainly
respect a relationship and we can
disagree on some things and that but I
think the words that you say in fact
argue for itl but you know there's a
pause here in some manufacturers not not
all that may give us some time to figure
out what it is moving forward you know
that there's another commission that may
be looking at this that's another reason
to pause and not to kill it uh so I you
know I certainly understand
the the hesitancy of people to jump in
feet first or head first
but that's what this you know that's
that's what the proposal for interim
study is all about and even the proposal
for a commission was all about so I just
uh I just think that the itl is just a
negative stop doing what we're doing so
that's my concern okay further
discussion yes please thank you chairman
uh I think interim study would and and
perhaps interim study and then folding
into something existing would help with
um charging infrastructure looking at
the charging infrastructure how that
impacts both tourism and commerce and uh
commuting commuting to work uh in
addition um represent J the mo the
motion is itl we'll speak on the motion
so yeah the I fully understand the
comment thank you y any any yes please
repr chinski yeah I support itl and um I
think the best commission that we have
is right out there now it's the consumer
and the consumer votes every day with
their pocketbook they they choose the
best products out there whether it's TVs
computers cars so I got no problem with
electric vehicles but they're already
highly subsidized I don't know what more
you can do but let the consumer pick
them out and then hopefully
manufacturers will give them exactly
what they want and they'll be happy to
buy it and I just wonder why we even got
to get involved with that thank you
thank you any further comment
please uh represent
Philadelphia yeah you
know we're at least four or five years
away from any kind of thank you
Improvement in uh electric
vehicles uh like Mr kazinski said the
public has spoken 75% of all the
electric vehicles made so far are
sitting in
Lots uh there's a reason for that
there's a lot of
dangers uh we're going to have to deal
with the the weight problem of the
vehicles at some point in time on our
roads and our bridges and uh our parking
garages uh there just I just think we're
stepping into this way too soon I think
we need a three or four year break
before we do and see what
transpires in the meantime to make these
Vehicles more safe and more readily
available thank you yes represent
Pon so I'd like to continue to the
conversation about interim study I'm
just looking uh projections for electric
vehicle sales um okay Bloomberg says
electric vehicle Market looks headed for
22% growth this
year uh NASDAQ EV trends for
2024 continued growth uh expected to
continue growing in 2024 and as
following another year in 2023 so
electric so I
think there is something to uh this
bill it's not ready for prime time I
certainly agree on that and but I would
like to agree to the point that just it
Ling the bill sends a message that this
state is hostile to electric vehicles
and it's growing that perhaps the state
has a role in planning on how this
growth is going to be
managed and so that this could be done
but again looking at what we already
have in place interim study is a great
way to okay we're that and and I
certainly appreciate all of your opinion
but let's let's focus on the itl motion
it would appear you're not in favor of
itl that is correct thank you very much
thank you and I apologize for the wrong
name they representive represent clud
here uh yes um it is going to be I've
really struggled L with this bill and
I've talked with the sponsor about it
and I heard her
presentation and I just want to say that
when it comes for a vote and I'm at the
first one I will vote against the itl
motion with all due respect to everybody
who's on the other side I don't think
it's a real partisan issue I if itl goes
uh approved I will support the committee
on the floor and hope that the uh the
commission and or the 10e plan can do
anything but I just think we need to do
more to promote electric
vehicles uh and I think to me this
commission at least can identify and see
if we can do anything so with reluctance
I will vote no on itl and if it itl was
somehow fail support interm study thank
you Mr chairman thank you I feel strong
thank you thank you some on the on the U
itl
motion okay yes please um
R SAR please uh thank you Mr chairman I
guess what I would say is is that I
heard at the beginning being said that
some of this topic of this particular
commission would be taken up in another
commission as long as I get a it's
commitment that that's going to happen
then I'd be willing to vote for the itl
thank
you yes representative yes I I I was and
once again I probably get the number on
was is it Bill 1631 CH yeah that's that
is correct
we have had a commission to study this
at least 10 years every 10 every two
years the players change everything
changed and they have to start from zero
last year I was fortunate enough to be
put on that committee and one of the
first things we realized is that it's
it's it's a broad scope number one it's
going to take some time and by changing
People every two years it accomplishes
next to nothing so our intent with this
new bill is to get the commission up and
running and then make it part of a
subcommittee of Public Works and
highways so that it will always be in
this room and as we we've solve various
facets how do we tax them H how how do
you how how do you charge them where do
we put charge as we solve individual
issues it was always the intent that
public works and highways Drive ding
that bus would put out the individual
bills so that we weren't having bills
willy-nilly that contradicted each other
you know they said you have to do it
this way and then oh by the way we
figured out another new way that was the
intent and that's why I put forth the
itl motion just that we don't need
conflicting commissions and that this
would be the purview of the new
semi-permanent commission thank you any
any further
discussion I think we've had
um a good conversation uh seeing none I
I am going to vote
itl um prior to calling the the vote I I
I'm still struck by the testimony that
the batteries uh and the fire Marshall's
testimony and I I believe there's a lot
of work that needs to be happened I'm
I'm going to key back to the point that
represent Mills said
the discussion on um on particulates in
the in the air and so forth I don't
think is something typically we cover in
this committee it was originally
assigned to uh Science and Technology I
will I will take the representative as
as Point as being a member of the
committee uh commission and there is
nothing that says that we can't handle a
a committee in our inside a study
committee inside side um if um If This
Were to pass so that we keep this
conversation alive and I would be
looking for members um uh of the
committee toh take up that charge and
we'll talk about that after so the
motion is itl uh if you're in favor of
the motion itl on House Bill 1510 you'll
signify by saying I or yes as if you
oppos nay or no uh with that Mr clerk
would you please pleas called the role
thank you Mr chairman Representative
cluder no representative Mills votes yes
repres representative
fidi representative Newton yeah
representative
kazinski representative
Bowen representative Boyd Boyd votes
High representative Melvin is excused
representative bogert yes representative
Connors yes Connor excuse
me representative Jack
yes representative Abbott
yes representative Edgar I
representative Faulkner
no representative Newman
no representative Eaton is excused
representative Peterson no
representative bone no repes
Representative jurus no chairman mccon
chairman votes
I Mr chair the motion itl passes
126 thank you no consent calendar yeah
definit thank you for put on regular
account I would be more than happy if
itl prevails to work on the commission
itself get to the commission of the
committee the committee comme I yes I
would I would like to form a committee
and and work on work on it inside this
uh inside here and if you can invite
someone over from science
that thank you for that okay we are we
are unable to move forward with our
second item which is House Bill 122 FN
until we we have an amendment so I would
like to exec from um the um I would like
to recess from the exec session on that
and we will
reschedule
we will come we will pause the do
presentation uh probably at 11:30 hoping
we can get an amendment by that time Mr
clerk Mr chairman I do have the raw
unofficial amendments here that I can
pass out so that the members can peruse
them oh okay while we're waiting for the
official Amendment okay and this is the
amendment for
1202 in its entirety
unofficially could I have one cop I
think I have it right here you do and do
I have the amendment that they just gave
us I apologize for representative
Alexander's Amendment yes yeah I one
copy of that I'll go speak with
out
do we want to announce that the reports
on the previous Bill need to be
done yeah I I
believe First Boyd will you work work on
a
uh yeah we need that by noon okay sounds
yeah to get something in the calendar is
Wednesday 1 so it has to
be
yeah and this is the calendar that it
has to be
in for for the committee members we had
a conversation last week uh that we were
going to try and meet tomorrow ahead of
the governor's address in our session um
that is is not going to happen we will
be in here next week as it says in the
calendar um in the posting we're not
meeting tomorrow in committee nor are we
meeting on Friday of this week I believe
we're meeting next Wednesday and next
Friday in the calendar to take up the
10year plan it's t is it Tuesday and
Friday I'm I'm gonna have to look
I
right with that um I would um like to uh
open up a presentation by New Hampshire
Department of
Transportation uh I would welcome um
commissioner forward to uh address and
whomever else you would like to at this
time I'm going to uh give you my apology
that I need to leave the committee uh
but we will um we will hear the
presentation and if the amendment's
ready we will we will pause or recess
that when you expect to do that I have
idea good morning um am I okay to start
uh commissioner cash I welcome you cast
I'd like to welcome you and your uh
dedicated um staff department heads for
being here with us today sincerely
appreciate the opportunity for you to
speak with the uh the committee and U I
apologize for having to leave represent
cier will be here and I'll see you I
will join you a little later very good
thank you uh Mr chairman um while while
the information is being handed out um
uh my name is Bill Cass I'm the
Commissioner of dot with me is Bill
oldenberg he's the director of project
development who oversees the development
of the 10-year plan every two years for
the Department I just wanted to give a
very brief introduction before uh
turning it over to bill for the
presentation um I see some new faces and
there some experienced faces with the
10-year plan so um just for a very high
level summary the the 10year plan is is
the state's um you know Transportation
Improvement plan for the next for the
next 10 years it is updated every two
years um and uh we have we roll it out
two more years so it always covers a 10e
a 10year span and I uh want to emphasize
that it is a transportation plan because
it does contain all modes of
transportation uh a lot of our
presentation is going to be focused on
uh the highway and bridge program
primarily because that is the largest
piece of the program um and it is the
area where we probably have the most
discretion but I do want to emphasize
that all of the federal funding all of
the funding for all the modes of
transportation that we receive and that
come through the department are
contained in the 10year plan so the
Aeronautics and the airport um uh
programs are contained in the 10year
plan all of the um all of the uh funding
and the programs for uh public
transportation and uh Railway are in the
10e plan as well too um bill will give a
a higher level overview of some of the
breakdown and pie charts of that but uh
um I did want to make sure I emphasize
that this is a uh full Transportation
plan while we have a lot of discussion
about the highway and bridge program it
does represent all modes of
transportation in the state um two years
ago when we updated the uh 10 a plan
before this commission there was a lot
of focus on uh recently passed Federal
authorization the bipartisan
infrastructure law or or the um the iig
which was our federal reauthorization
for the next uh six years at that that
point and uh when we were here uh two
years ago um that bill that
reauthorization had just been passed so
there was a lot of highlevel information
about the additional levels of funding
and and stuff but um how it was fully
implemented was still kind of kind of
being worked on so uh a lot of the
presentation two years ago was focused
on the amount of federal funding and
stuff that came from the
iiga this 10-year plan really focuses on
on the implementation of of that plan
and the delivery of the iig so we have a
little bit of uh look back but mainly
it's um very status very
um um you know sustainable in terms of
uh what we're doing in terms of
implementing that uh program so some of
the updates through this plan have been
looked at uh uh adjusting everything for
inflation and taking a fresh look at
estimates um we have looked at
incorporating the next two years of
regional Planning commiss Commission
priority ities um there is a strong
focus on the additional Federal funding
that we're providing to Municipal
Bridges um and uh a number of the
programs and um and other elements one
thing at this this this round of um the
10-year plan was the solicitation for uh
a a certain flavor of federal funding
for the congestion mitigation and air
quality program um um uh and that had a
lot of discussion and debate we'll
discuss some of those changes but um
that that was an element of this ten
year plan as well too so without further
Ado I just wanted to give that brief
over over overview of where we are and
what what the 10year plan is uh and with
that I'll turn it over to uh uh Bill
oldenberg director of project
development to walk you through the
presentation that uh that we have and
again it is fairly high level there is a
lot of
information um we want to give you a a
flavor and hit the high points but
certainly through this or the public
hearing of the subsequent work sessions
want to work with the committee uh and
make sure you understand and get all of
your questions um uh satisfactorily
addressed so
Bill thank you commissioner um I
recognize it um you're you're sort of
under a time crunch so I've reduced my
4-Hour presentation to about half hour
45 minutes so um and it it it has
actually pretty diff a little 10-year
plan humor it's not a very humorous
topic but um it it is the culmination of
a a year and a half's worth of work so
far and uh we sort of see a light at the
end of the tunnel um so just last week
um just sort of the handouts that we
gave you last week and what we just put
on your in front of you so uh last week
you should have received a 10-year plan
book um that inside that was the
transmittal letter from the governor uh
to the um house Public Works um uh on uh
that transmitt there was also a change
log of changes that had occurred during
the gaset process and through the
governor's phase um a listing of uh the
CAC project summaries as well as a
corridor study map so in front of you
today uh is a copy of the presentation
I'll be going over um and a a series of
maps to help you understand some of the
some of the different aspects of of our
transportation system uh one is a a
federal aid map which shows you the
different tiers of roads and and those
roads which are ferally eligible uh
versus those that aren't federally
eligible and we'll we'll talk about what
that means in a little bit uh We've
included a map of the turnpike system
the transit system public airports um
the active Rail lines and we have
revived Ed the corridor plan the map
that we gave you last week because we
realized we printed an old copy and was
missing a corridor so U please discard
the the one we gave you last week and
also we found an error in the change one
of the change logs so we gave you a new
change log so um on the on the gaset
face so with
that um I will begin the presentation
covers a a a sort of flows from a recap
of the tenure plan process talk about
highlevel funding overview the 10-year
plan strategies that we used um in in
investing in in the assets and how we've
uh used and and uh plan to expend the
funds um and then I talk we talk about
the federal and state programs um that
we um use to and invest in so on slide
three what I'll try to do is I'll
remember to tell you what page I'm on uh
to keep you going so on slide three this
is an overview uh flow of of the 10-year
plan process so this process started in
the summer of 22 where we reach out to
the regional planning commissions to get
um a community and and and Regional uh
priorities um those are reviewed and uh
ultimately uh voted ranked by the
communities and brought into the draft
10year plan uh in april-ish and May um
of
23 so this started uh a year and a half
ago last year we worked to the regional
planning commissions to bring those
projects forward um in June through
October we began uh the gaset phase uh
which is the governor's advisory
Commission on Intermodal Transportation
it's the five executive counselors and
the commissioner um we review uh the the
plan the strategy the funding with them
uh discuss the approach that we're
taking in this 10-year plan and then um
we hold the the gas uh group hold uh
public hearings to gather input on the
projects on the on the plan um and then
those are reviewed uh changes are
recommended through by gaset and then
that is ultimately uh transmitted to the
governor um for his review and comment
that was done in December and uh the
governor then reviewed commented main
changes that are shown in the in the
change log um and that was transmitted
in January 10th to be exact um uh to the
legislature uh to begin this process so
on page four and five we sort of
summarized the dates um that we held
these meetings that we that we did the
reviews um I won't I won't belabor with
you with reading them all I think the
the key one uh is from uh September 7th
to October 25th we held uh 24 Public
hearings um to review the tenear plan
throughout the
state
um and um on slide six there is a
summary of that public
testimony um we held like I said 24
Public hearings there were seven hybrid
hearings um the public testimony uh is
663 pages long uh summarizes every
meeting who attended what the comments
were um so if you if you want to there
it's available online um on in the
10year plan on on Do's web page um to
apprise those to see what those comments
were to summarize um
briefly we we heard a lot of support for
Transit uh we had a lot of um input um
uh and testimony from the mobility
Managers from the transit agencies and
from the public um that supported um
Transit uh expansion of Transit and also
supported and we're thankful and
appreciative of the additional money
that was passed in hb2 um uh last last
um budget cycle uh for additional funds
to support the transit system on the
project side we heard a lot of report on
the Newcastle Causeway project
um from a an Outreach and a a Ruckus
standpoint uh there was a lot of uh
comments about the a couple Tilton
projects that we had um and also the
Manchester exit 6 and s project um uh
also got a lot of lot of uh concern and
questions so um we've addressed those um
all of those projects you can see in the
change log uh were addressed and and
through the gaset process and uh in that
so I'll talk about those projects in a
little bit so on on page seven and eight
of the presentation what I want to do is
highlight a little bit of what's in this
book so um the information that's in
this book uh and and how to read it and
the first few pages you'll see a lot of
charts and graphs it's basically how we
slice and dice uh the funding we
received the different buckets that the
funding comes in um some of it's
mandated funding some of it's Federal
funding the state the turnpike funding
um so it it lists the funding that um
that comes in it also lists the the the
investment strategies and how that that
funding is spent and the different modes
um Etc so you'll see a lot of
information on on uh money in and and
money out um in those in the in the
graphs and how that's spent the
remaining 274 Pages um are project Pages
uh an example is on page eight so each
project in the 10-year plan uh has a
specific project it's they're they're
they're listed by Town
name uh list the road the description of
what the project is and it also breaks
out uh the different phases of our
project so there's basically three
phases a design phase a rightaway phase
and a construction phase and you'll see
that listed as preliminary engineering
that's basically the design uh RightWay
if we need to acquire any RightWay like
easements or or or Acquisitions of of of
property um that's where that is the the
funding and the years are shown and the
construction so the years represent when
we would start um those
activities and then the funding
represents the amount of money and then
also we list the program um that the the
the funding is is coming out of um
there's also some other information that
is listed is in the comments you'll see
where that project came from this
project is the example came through um
uh statford Regional Planning Commission
uh through the 10-year plan process back
in uh 2023 so gives you an example of of
what that information is for all these
projects um in the in the back the last
Pages you'll see a bunch of projects
that are listed as programmatics so what
those programmatics
are um we we bucket funding for projects
um for for programs or types of of
projects that we want to do um to set
aside money as placeholder but we don't
have actual projects yet so an example
of that is um maybe our our our highway
safety Improvement program we get $12
million a year uh in that in that
program we don't know exactly um what
projects we'll be working on in the
outer years of the plan so we set aside
that $12
million and then as projects are created
sort of like a ledger in a a checkbook
we create a project that money is
reduced from the $12 million and that
project is created so you'll see these
programmatics listed that um are really
placeholders uh to make sure that we we
spend the money in those programs um and
and not spend it elsewhere um as
projects are created we we we then
reduce that amount so uh if you look
you'll see in the in the beginning years
the the numbers might look a little low
in the outer years they're they're very
consistent and that's why we've created
projects in this in the near future uh
to use those funds so um I
it's we do a great deal of our
maintenance and preservation this way
our Paving programs our Bridge
maintenance our our Bridge Replacements
um that that is how we we bucket our
money we don't know 10 years from now
what road we're going to pave but we
want to make sure that we have money to
pave those roads so that is why we we
sort of bucket the the money in and and
show it as a a programmatic um so
probably a longer
convoluted uh answer to that but uh on
on page nine uh talking about the
funding and where the where the funding
comes from the total program is 5
billion do over uh 10 years so about
$500 million per year Federal Highway
funding is the largest share of that at
about $280 million a year or 56% of the
program
there are other federal funds that we
get as the commissioner says we're not
just a a highway and bridge program we
also get um uh rail funds from federal
rail
Administration uh Federal Transit funds
uh Federal Aviation funds for airports
that funding represents about 15% of the
program about $76 million per year we'll
talk about those specific programs in a
little bit we also on the state side we
have Turnpike programs that represent um
about 16% of the funds and that
represents um our our Turnpike renewal
and replacement program our maintenance
program then our capital projects then
we also have state funding through
betterment uh state aid Bridge uh and SB
367 that represents about 12% of the
funds uh $60 million per year and we'll
talk about a little bit of how this
breaks down um on in the next couple
slides but you can see that from a
federal standpoint um Federal Highway
makes up the majority of the funds that
we
receive on on page 10 we wanted want to
summarize a little bit you know the
roads um and the different tiers uh of
roads that we've created so not all
roads in New Hampshire or any state are
created the same and we've broken the
the different cheers or different roads
into into tier so a tier one road is
basically an interstate or divided
highway down to a tier four road which
is a secondary Highway um unnumbered
State Route
so 4600 miles of roads that
sorry okay excuse me Mr oldenberg are
you open to questions I have a Committee
Member who wants to ask I don't mean to
interrupt or would rather
wait or just I I can answer questions
now or we can wait until the end that's
okay would you want to wait or want to
ask now
represent the question is is pertaining
to this page so okay it might make sense
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question uh am I correct
we we have the formal definition class
one through six roads these tiers it
seems like are an administrative thing
that the do does that really doesn't
have doesn't have any legal effect
beyond the class one through am I
correct on that it's not defined in
statured anywhere correct correct this
is a sort sort of a self-imposed system
so if you went to the class system you
know the class 1 through six really the
state roads are class one and two um so
what we've done is we've broken those
roads down a little bit further um a
tier one road being an interstate a tier
2 Road being a a a major um Statewide
Corridor like Route 16 or route nine um
and then the tier four or tier three and
four roads are those those minor roads
uh secondary roads and you know we I
affectionately call the tier four roads
is state roads that you wouldn't really
realize were state roads and we question
somebody the state roads they they they
go through a community or a town and end
in that town and don't really have a
regional significance but they are a
state road um and why I really wanted to
talk about that was this this comes into
um the federal eligibility um a lot of
the roads and we have another slide
coming up
is of the 4600 miles of Roads 1100 miles
of them aren't eligible for federal
funds and they rely strictly on state
funds so we really want to just break
this up and let you let you know that um
we break it up by cheers to sort of
break it down a little bit more than the
class system because we we sort of need
to because some of the roads are
eligible and some aren for federal aid
and we need to to be able to separate
those out
um okay thank you and appreciate you
taking that question so you know I guess
please continue M I guess however
however oh I'm sorry commissioner yeah
oh I was just G to say however it works
for the for the commission we uh uh for
the committee if uh if there are
questions as we go we certainly uh okay
so it's all right and I don't mean there
different way we just want to get
through the information we want to be as
efficient with your time as as possible
but certainly as we get through what we
wanted to make sure that uh that you
understand things as well too so please
yeah there question okay I appreciate
your flexibility and members of the
committee have questions but otherwise I
please continue with your presentation
great thank you so from a high level
overview on on page 11 um we we talk
about the Federal Highway funding um and
the commissioner sort of touched on on
this with the federal reauthorization so
in the last 10year plan cycle we were at
the very beginning of of getting the the
infra or infrastructure investment and
jobs the iiga which then was passed into
law as the the bill law the bipartisan
infrastructure law we don't call it bill
because we just swing our heads back and
forth because everybody's name Bill at
the department no only kidding um so we
refer to at the iig um so that
reauthorization took place in 2002 and
it set to expire in 202 or sorry 2022
and it set to expire in
2026 so it it really only covers 2025
and 26 of of the 10-year plan that
funding um and is is constrainted in the
10year plan currently at $234 million
per
year we assume one of our strategies is
that when that expires it may or may not
be extended um and or there may be an
additional reauthorization we don't know
what that future is but we have assumed
in the 10-year plan that we're going to
have that level funding continue at that
same level so one of the strategies is
to assume that we would receive at least
$234 million per year in the remaining
out years of the 10-year plan
historically we haven't seen a decrease
in federal funds uh but we can also
guarantee an increase um so we've
assumed level funding uh to be
conservative one of the other um issues
that we dealt with in this year plan was
an increased um inflation rate as
everybody knows inflation is increased
uh we've seen a skyrocketing escalation
uh in
construction uh bid prices material
costs supply chain issues with
contractors and that all those issues
have related into higher than than
anticipated bid prices on our project so
typically in the past 10-year plan um we
had a infl infation rate of 2.8% per
year um basically what we've done is
every year um every project is escalated
2 point the
cost let me step back the way we
estimate the project is today's dollars
we use today's dollars to estimate what
the Project's worth and then we we
inflate um every year those dollars
until we get to the year that the
project is in the 10-year plan so it'll
it'll it accounts for inflation um
escalation and cost to some degree the
last 10year plan it was 2.8% previous
plans it was about 2% because of the
inflation escalation rate um we've done
an analysis um and reviewed um
anticipated inflation over that 10-year
period and we've increased Deb inflation
rate to
3.7% per year and all the projects in
the the 10-year plan I mention that
basically because without adding a
single project to the plan just
increasing the inflation uh increase the
the cost of the plan by $100
million so that that is a component um
and in funding the plan uh is that
increase in
inflation uh as I said some of the the
bid prices that we've seen lately and
and if you follow the bids that we've
been receiving we've
as we try to catch up and anticipate um
they just keep going up one of the one
of the things that we do is we have a
construction cost index that monitors
bid prices for certain items structural
steel pavement uh you know excavation
gravel and so we monitor that and we see
Trends and you know a simple one is
structural steel in the last year we've
seen structural steel costs uh almost go
up a 100% in bids so
um I think you've seen that in some of
the bids that we received for the
general Sullivan Bridge uh the cbook
Hampton Bridge the the the bid price for
for some of these items is just um you
know been uh unprecedented um and and
hard to follow um from a from a a a an
estimating standpoint so um one of the
things that um the other component is uh
the programmatic um level I talked about
what a programmatic is
so we program about a these
programmatics represent about 120 $130
million a year in the plan if you added
them all up um we assume that we'll fund
those programmatics at the same level um
as they are in the 10-year plan in the
two new years that were added so we've
just added the same programmatic level
funding
um in uh the the outer years in 33 and
34 that existed uh in the in the rest of
the
plan those programmatics are shown on on
pages 234
2374 or of the
plan
um and one of the things that we did do
if you compared it to the last 10-year
plan we use the funding levels from the
the the 21 through 30 plan not the 23
through 32 plan not the last plan and
the reason for that is we didn't know
exactly what what buckets what flavors
of funds we were going to get with the
iig we knew we were going to get so much
more money um so some of the way we did
that was we we put some of those funds
for for Paving and bridges in the
programmatics as as sort of placeholders
because we didn't really know where they
were going to be allocated um and so
that's why we didn't use the last
10-year plan funding because it was sort
of distorted a little because of that
unknown uh factor of where um that
additional funding would come
from um on page 12 one of the things
that we did receive and the commissioner
touched on this was with the iiga came
some new federal
programs um those new federal programs
uh there were several uh Bridge programs
the the bridge bill money uh the mo bill
money which is Municipal owned
Bridge money um and Bridge exempt funds
so some of the keys to this is that
allows uh the use of federal funds on
Municipal Bridges
um and that is sort of
unprecedented uh to to be able to use uh
federal funds on on bridges that aren't
really F federally eligible and this is
because the the recognition that a lot
of the communities um you know
throughout the country don't have um the
funding to replace some and and repair
some of the bridges that they have so
this was an opportunity to for us to
expand on um uh funding you know
Municipal Bridges uh in the last
cycle um we were able to use the funds
to
accelerate a lot of our state bridge Aid
Bridges so we moved a lot of those
bridges forward and we're able to to to
to move a lot of do a lot of those work
those bridges and and uh for the
communities and what that allows us to
do is now back feed um the the rest of
the 10-year plan uh with these funds and
we'll talk about it a little later but
we were able to add uh 56 Municipal
bridges into the the 10-year plan uh
using this funding so um that was a
a a big win uh for the municipalities um
with the the new program um the nevi
program is new and is is being
implemented so that's the national
electric vehicle infrastructure program
um creates uh alternative fuel corridors
um and places um
uh ALS ultimately will'll construct uh
and place electric vehicle Chargers
along those corridors throughout the
state uh there's protect funds which is
a Statewide and um Coastal resiliency
program uh allows us to uh to use that
funding to create uh uh uh infrastruct
or infrastructure Coastal and and
Statewide um uh improvements for storm
damage um Coastal resilience Etc there's
also the carbon Reduction Program
similar to CAC um we're allowed to uh to
fund certain programs that um that
reduce our carbon footprint so EV um and
a lot of the programs that qualify for
CMAC also qualify for this program
except there isn't an air quality
component to it like CMAC has there's
also a new discretionary grants I did
not list them all because they're
there's at least 20 new discretionary
grants that are out there some of them
um states can apply for some of them
just Regional planning commissions and
communities can uh apply for um so
there's a plethora of of new grant
opportunities um the the struggle we
have is the eligibility and the rules
and the restrictions don't all come out
at the same time and I think we'll hear
about that with in the CAC program is um
understanding the rules and the and the
restrictions um is something that's very
complicated um so that does yes sir okay
all right sorry yeah representative
alone please thank you for taking thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question so just on the discretionary
grants do you have a dollar figure on
that for how much money that the state
has um so we do not we don't budget for
um or you won't
see anticipated
uh grants in our 10year plan we apply
for them and if we're awarded them then
you'll see them so like the raise grant
for um the general suiv Bridge we
receive $20
million but one of the things would be
so a lot of the federal funding and
stuff that we talk about is is Formula
funding so that's formula that is a
portion to the States and it's it's um
it's guaranteed the discretionary grants
are competitive grants programs that are
set up nationally um there was a lot of
money in the iig set aside for these
discretionary grants um so when you ask
how much the state gets it's it's un
undetermined we do try to compete um uh
discretionary grants that that that we
have received we do reflect in the
10-year plan Bill mentioned the go uh
General Sullivan bridge and there are
some other projects um but by and large
because it's because it's it's
discretionary because it's competitive
um we don't we don't budget for it if we
if we are successful in in receiving
some Grant funds um it helps it helps
def Fray costs and inflation but it's
hard to budget for that because it's
it's like winning the it's like winning
the lottery you don't necessarily budget
for winning the lottery you have a
followup for some belong yes followup
just real quick so uh you're tracking
how much money is these discretionary
grants come to to New Hampshire over the
years or okay yes and one more where
would I find that
information uh we could we we could uh I
don't know if it's um it's probably
scattered in several different programs
but um we can get to I mean we keep a
list of the program of the discretionary
grants that that we get we could get you
that information for thank you so much
okay yeah thank you thank you
commissioner Cass and uh Mr fron that
question please continue I I I would
just mention that some of the some of
the the grants that are that the
communities apply for and get are direct
recipient grants so the money goes
directly to those and we don't have an
involvement so we don't oversee some of
those we have we do have a listing of
them uh but we don't we don't
necessarily oversee or manage or even
are involved in it in some of those
those grants um
on page 13 uh talk a little bit about
State funding and where the state funds
come from really the three sources of
State funds are Turnpike betterment and
SB
367 uh Turnpike Revenue comes from tolls
so toll Revenue uh and bonding that
represents about $48 million per year
and just a reminder that the toll system
Turnpike system is an Enterprise System
it's self-contained so the so money does
stays within the the turnpike system
doesn't it can't be used on anything but
the turnpike system
we don't add Federal money to the
turnpike system to the and the tolls
stay in the turnpike system so it's a
self-contained unit uh the betterment
side which is our state gas tax um road
toll three cents a gallon we um that
involves it collects about $21 million
per year and SB
367 which was a a short term uh increase
in the gas tax uh 4.2 cents per gallon
uh
represents a revenue of about $34
million per year got a little discussion
coming up about uh about that and um uh
the sunsetting of that uh program as
well uh so impacts to the state system
one of the things that we've we've
noticed in in this plan is uh we monitor
traffic volume we use the traffic volume
counts as uh a key indicator uh because
more people on the road we collect more
tolls more people on the road they buy
more gas um so those are the two that's
sort of our main indicator of of Revenue
projections on on the on the state and
the Turnpike
System since 2019 if you if you look at
2019 Through The covid Years where we
saw a drastic decrease in traffic back
up to current um you know we had
projected from 2019 what traffic would
be in
2024 um we're about 3 to 4% less um than
what we had projected in
2019 so over the last couple 10year plan
Cycles um we've had to adjust Revenue
projections uh from a toll side and from
a gas tax side uh based upon that that
lower traffic volume and what that
really relates to from a a Turnpike
standpoint
um
is as I stated total revenue in we use
that that those funds to fund
maintenance and capital projects in the
turnpike system we can't really spend
more money than we have um so what that
means is we have
a we have a a model and a a prediction
of project costs versus um project
expenditures versus Revenue Vue in and
we need to make sure that that's that's
sort of level so one of the things that
we show with some of our major Turnpike
projects is that we we would have to
delay some of them um we'll talk about
that in a little bit but that was with
the basically the reduction in in total
revenue in we couldn't afford to to
build all the projects on time as
schedule uh with the with the current
costs uh on the betterment side
um that reflects with a decrease in
funding um it also reflects a a decrease
in our Paving program we use that that
money to pave and on S SP 367 that
decrease in Revenue uh also uh shows a
decrease in the availability for state
aid Bridge funding um as well as
um uh the uh Paving program so one thing
I would caveat that with is we review
this every 10-year plan cycle so there's
adjustments every two years in these
projections in in this Revenue
prediction but our snapshot in time
right now that's sort of what um what
we've looked
at I would also say that it's not just
people traveling um from you know a toll
you know a road toll Revenue gas tax uh
it's also the increase in uh miles per
gallon of vehicles gas
uh the the the greater miles per gallon
they get the less gas they use so we
also seeing just a reduction in the in
the gallons uh that are used yes sir so
um again represent B would like to ask a
question go ahead please thank you thank
you for taking my question um you had
mentioned that uh as we're modifying
some of the highways tier one type
projects that you're incorporating EV
administers the EV stations if the state
is paying for the station itself to get
the charging station itself to go in
place who
administers the charging apparatus and
who collects the revenues or is their
revenues generated by someone plugging
stations he's got his head down um yes
so no yes so the the nevi program what
we did was we developed a plan and that
plan in involved what corridors we were
going to invest or in charging stations
we've put out uh
a a request for proposal in
RFP um for the funding that's available
it's about $17 million total over the
fiveyear program um and people are it's
a competitive process uh for proposals
for
companies uh to put in charging stations
we will fund those charging stations
some of them
are from what we what we can tell it's
it's electric companies who are working
with private entities um to put in these
charging stations they do have the abil
so it's a pay for the electricity pay
for the charging stations pay for it
installed and then uh the the the
company who runs it owns it uh has the
ability to charge uh the consumer um at
the at the charger uh for the
electric thank you please
continue
um so on on page 14 continued sort of
discussion this is sort of a highlight
of House Bill 2 um uh that came about
last last uh budget cycle at the 2425
budget um so I had mentioned uh some of
the the Outreach from the transit folks
um appreciative with for the the funding
that was given to them that was um an
increase of of $1.89 million that was in
house bill to last last budget what that
did was
um uh FTA Federal Transit Administration
increased funds available to the state
that requires a state match to accept
those funds and to use those funds we
don't have state money um to to match so
the the legislature and their their
their kindness um increased and set
aside $1.89 million so that we could use
State money on to match that Federal
Federal program that and I I tend to
believe that this afternoon during the
public hearing you might hear testimony
about the use of that Transit funds and
and how well it was received and what
came out of um uh that funding so
um that is uh that was uh
just some of the some of the funding
that came out of House Bill 2 last year
and and then also out of House Bill too
came uh $10 million uh block grant aid
funds were directed to municipalities as
well as $10 million for local Bridges
those were directed communities uh in
fiscal year 2024 those don't show up in
the 10-year plan uh but it allowed those
communities uh to advance repairs and
and replace local uh Bridges and and
Road repairs um so on page
15 talk about the funding and the
investment Strate strategies um where
the where the funding goes um that uh
that we
receive so this is shows a distribution
of the funds um and where the funds are
spent as I said it's a 10 it's A5
billion doll program The Road and Bridge
mode which is pavement Bridges um our ma
what we show as mandated programs uh
individual projects roadside and debt
that all comes out of the road
uh and bridge mode represents 84% of the
program or
$420 million per year the other modes
Transit rail airport represents 16% of
the plan um and in the investment about
$80 million per year on average so on
page 16 we talk a little bit about if I
if I could hold hold uh just for a
moment the
um um I'd like to pause the um the the
discussion or presentation at this point
in time so that we could take back up a
executive session and then we'll
continue on if that's all right with the
Department absolutely I appreciate the
deadline so I will um House Bill 1202
I'd like to open Kamar recess executive
session on um house bill uh 122
FN um you have an amendment before
you and um yes I recognize the
clerk uh I I move ought to pass uh Mr
224-7629 Amendment before we proceed on
this okay if you're in favor of the
amendment which I have is
0706 H uh that was just distributed if
You' signify by saying I I any
opposed motion carries unanimous
actually
repres
I
I usually ask for a raise the hand I
apologize so the amendment the amendment
carries unanimously which brings us back
to house bill 122 FN as
amended any discussion on the
bill um accept a motion for approval Mr
chairman I would move House Bill 122 FN
as
amended okay be approved as ought to
pass thank you the second second that
second by Mills now for discussion House
amended seeing no
discussion um I would call for the role
chair representative IIA uh
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fedolfi
yes representative Newton yes
representative kazinski yes
representative Bowden yes representative
Boyd vo votes I representative Melvin is
excused representative bogert yes
representative Connor yes representative
Jack yes representative Abbott yes
representative Ed Edgar hi
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton is excused representative Peterson
yes representative balone yes
representative jurus
yes chairman mccon chairman votes I Mr
chair the motion ought to pass as
190 thank you
consent count consent any objection to
consent seeing none we will put it on
consent thank you excuse me Mr chair who
made the motion to op to pass with
Amendment okay I just want to be sure
thank you sure that you're not the
person writing right
you quick point of order yes please the
previous vote was 12 to6 which comes up
to 18 the clerk coded 190 I just want to
we we vote on a previous
vote I think everybody nobody's
left I don't know I still have it let's
it need that yep I
know it's okay I haven't slept in 48
hours I've done like three mons since
I'm back at BC I'm I'm used to this this
is good pres boy do you want me to uh
you want to start in on this and I can
join you or what would
you okay thank
you
um while while we're talking about that
14 19
68 which I believe was the Conway rail
Bill take this up in a moment I need to
clerk
anden we have 20 members so those who
missing it would be think 18 I think
according to my
me Mr chair I apologize I misnumbered
180 thank you and thank you for catching
that representative boy wh off blurbing
as we speak all right um with
that um we we are finished with our
executive session we return back to the
presentation by do I apologize for the
delay thank you exent not a not a
problem at all um so on page 16 we talk
a little bit about the strategies that
we used in the 10-year plan I I won't go
over them again because I've talked
about some of them but basically um
we're focusing on maintenance and
preservation of the existing roads um
and investing in those core programs uh
pavment roads Bridges getting Bridges
off the red list and um and fixing um
the infrastructure uh Culver's gar rail
payment markings
Etc um Federal
reauthorization uh maintaining um the
projects that are in the 10-year plan
and uh we as I said we took account of
inflation and escalation in costs um and
considered the new projects uh from the
regional planning commissions entering
in the new the new years of the 10e plan
on page 17 talk a little bit about the
federal aid programs that exist so um I
as I like to say the federal government
doesn't give us a giant Lottery check
and all the money at once uh they divvy
it up and put rules and restrictions on
each little bucket so um we do have
primary funding which is Highway and
bridges and you sort of see how it's
broken into different programs but we
also have mandated Federal programs that
we we are required to um to develop and
and uh create projects in highway safety
r rail Crossing programs uh CMAC program
to program Etc these are all formula
allocations so commissioner touched on
this formula allocation so you get
Federal gas tax all goes into the
federal system there's a a formula in
which how much New Hampshire gets of
that money there's also a formula on how
that money is broken down into these
little separate buckets so we get um we
get our allocation broken up by formula
we don't generally don't get adjust it
doesn't get adjusted up or down either
way um except by uh by the federal
government uh based upon Revenue in uh
so each as I said each program contains
specific requirements and eligibility um
so that's something we have to go
through and and when we talk about say
the nvi program there's certain
requirements that go into uh the
electric vehicle icle charging there's
certain requirements uh for a project to
get into the highway safety Improvement
program um and so that's sort of the the
rules that we we deal with uh on the
turnpike side which is slide
18 we break the the turnpike uh program
into two two buckets renewal and
replacement um basically renewal and
replacement sounds sounds like it is we
spent about $20 million uh preserving
maintaining and upgrading the existing
system uh the turnpike Capital program
are our major projects and these are
probably the biggest projects that
you'll find in the 10year plan they tend
to be mostly Interstate projects the
most extensive type of
projects this is where I'll hesitate and
take a pause because this is one of the
harder things to explain so in the
beginning we talked about due to the
toll Pike turn Turnpike toll Revenue
decrease that some of the projects had
to be delayed and moved out one of the
things that we also heard that that I
mentioned in public testimony was uh
Manchester exit 6 and 7 there was a lot
of consternation about moving that
project outside the 10-year plan so we
reviewed the funding uh took a a finer
look at it we looked at so so if you
think about this as um uh sort of as a a
a household budget you have money in
your bank account and then you receive a
paycheck so you get total revenue and
then you have you have an outlay you
have a project to do and you have money
spent we
don't we the way the a project is spent
it isn't all spent at once it's spent
over every month so a project bills so
there's sort of a a smoothing out of the
expenditures what we want to make sure
is we don't expend more money than we
take in and we have have allocated so we
try to smooth out that expenditures
versus uh funding
so what we did is we relooked at the
Nasha marac Bedford project the first
one listed is about $227
million that actually consists of five
projects one is already done two more
are basically under construction right
now so the other two um one happens to
be an extremely large project $120
million um are yet to come so we looked
at that expenditure and how that would
be molded and and and
adjusted we also looked at
um moving the Manchester exit 6 and 7
project all back in the
plan so that created sort of a spike at
the end of the end of the plan um
and I will mention the bo conquered
project it it shows $171 million that's
only the turnpike portion so that
project is is a $500 million project
$330 million of it is federally
funded so that project
expands uh quite a few years and what we
were able to do is review where we
anticipated expending federal funds and
Turnpike funds and be able to use that
Turnpike funding and move the projects
around the the thing with Bo conquered
is right now it's just one gigantic
project we're not going to build it as
one gigantic project we'll it'll be
broken into pieces to be built so we can
we have the ability to adjust the
spending for turnpikes and and fill in
those some of the
years so bringing the the Manchester
exit 6 and s project did create sort of
a bump in in the end we are able to
smooth out the spending and and and make
it meet you know expenditures versus
revenue and until the outer years and
what we realized is um that the turnpike
has a bond of a a a $200 million bond
that is out there we have still have
five or $50 million worth of bond
Authority that we haven't used if we use
that Bond um in the outer years of the
10-year plan it allows us to satisfy the
the accountants that um were within
budget and and to smooth out that that
uh expenditure so we were able to adjust
these projects bring Manchester back
into the 10-year plan uh and be able to
accomplish all this um but it would
require us uh showing uh bonding that
$50 million using that Authority in the
outer years of the plan as I said with
the the sort of the gas tax revenue the
turnpike revenue is the same this
adjusts every two years um this you know
by the time we get uh to needing that
Bond we're going to go through this
process three or four more times um so
there's fluctuations and variability in
that but it was it was an exercise that
we needed to do to be able to to to say
that we could build these projects and
stay within the budget um so that's how
we uh we were able to accomplish that on
page
19 talk a little bit about um the state
uh funding the federal eligibility and
um those roads that are not eligible so
this is the map uh that you
have so of the 4600 miles 3,400 of them
are eligible for federal funds and the
1100 aren't the the ones that aren't uh
eligible for federal funds that's where
we use our betterment funding for and
and are tifia pledged SP 367
funds um those that's the only money
that we have uh to be able to use on
those roads the problem we'll get to it
probably on the next slide um is that
the SB 367 tifia pledge Paving money
really expires in
2025 and that will mean uh our ability
to pave those non-eligible roads
decreases
tremendously um and you know we do have
limited um limited State funds to use
for Paving and that's shown on the next
page on on on page 20 our betterment
funds that we use for that that Paving
um we spent about three $13 million on
Paving using the betterment funds s SP
367 to 4.2 cents a gallon we've been
able to use about $20 million of that on
Paving and and Bridge projects so let me
step back and and as a reminder so back
when we were doing the I9 3 Sing to
Manchester project we took out a tifia
alone so that we could accelerate the um
the construction of those projects that
allowed us uh to get them done much
sooner than we could if we just used
federal funds to pay back that tifia
loan legislature passed s SP 367 created
this 4.2 send gas test that was
specifically dedicated to pay back the
tifia loan but it also had a few other
sections to it so 12% of that that
Revenue that comes in goes to block
Grand a that's about $4 million a year
the we also had Debt
Service we were able to use uh some of
the funds for State Bridge aid program
to be able to fund Municipal Bridges and
then we had this tifia pledged Paving
and uh and red listed Bridge work so the
way the loan was restructured in the
very beginning
um we were only required to pay interest
payments that left basically 20 million
$23 million that we could use for this
tifia Pudge Paving it allowed us to use
the state funds to to pave the roads uh
and and and repair
Bridges so in
2025 that debt um is due so we have to
convert that pledge Paving $20 million
and pay the debt so that Paving the
ability to use that funds to PVE goes
away so on page 21 we short sort of show
the the the accounting of that and where
this s SP
367 uh Debt Service payment comes from
so started in
2015 uh the First Column is the the the
revenue in Municipal block grant Aid
funding and then the repayment of the
loan and you you'll see in 2026 where
that increases to $23 million because
that loan is due that's where the pay
that payment goes what you'll notice is
that that that funding that 23 million
that we weren't paying goes directly
into that tifia pledged Paving and
Bridge repairs which is the second to
last column so you'll see that 20
million doll so this allowed us to be
able to to pave roads that weren't
federally El ible um and really keep
them in good repair before we were
allowed to do this we we received calls
continually on these tier three tier
four roads on how deplorable the
condition was and it really came down to
we didn't have the funds to pave them we
didn't have the funds to repair them and
I think the use of this funding over the
last 10 years has allowed us to make
drastic increases in the condition of
those roads and um and and and basically
reduce the the the amount of red listed
Bridges as well so on page 22 we talk a
little bit about what the ramifications
are of not having that $20
million and you can sort of see how
valuable that was for us the top graph
shows the Centerline miles paved you
know currently we've been Paving over
400 miles per year
and the the Bold blue line at the bottom
if that $20 million uh of s367 goes away
we'll show a decrease of about 200 miles
per year in our ability to pave so
almost half of the paving program was
the S SP
367 and the bottom line shows the
decrease in the fair good condition of
the roads we've been able to maintain
87% of our roads in Fair good shape
um because of this Paving or because of
this this this this
funding and it shows the less you pave
the worst condition the roads get and
you see a sort of a a proportional deg
degradation in the condition of the
roads which is the bottom Blue Line in
that condition phase so what the other
lines represent is we did a litmus test
we wanted to see what Revenue we would
need to pave the roads to bring the
conditions up and we look looked at the
Orange Line shows adding about $8
million um a year uh into that program
it it brings up the paving brings up the
condition uh the other remaining line is
a is an additional $1 million or or $19
million so basically replacing the $20
million with $19 million of Paving and
it shows being able to maintain that
Paving rout and be able to maintain that
that pavement condition so
in the 10-year plan this is sort of our
biggest challenge is where do we get
funds to fill in that hole that's
created by um the the reduction in the
in the S SP 367
Paving um and I will will add that in
the waterfall chart that you see the
when the loan is paid in
2034 that entire program expires so once
the pay the loan is goes away the 2. or
the 4.2 Cent a gallon D tax goes away so
the blocker Aid goes away as well as um
the the S the State Bridge a goes away
so um I would just note that so some of
the other programs on on page 23 so as
as the commissioner stay we're not just
Highway and bridges even though that's
all I've talked about uh uh we also uh
dedicate about $3 million a year in
active Transportation those are complete
streets projects multi-use paths uh
pedestrian Bridges sidewalks expanded
shoulders uh rail trail programs so uh
we do invest in in those um those
programs as well on page 24 um so we we
highlighted some of the the individual
programs that we we heard about during
the 10-year plan the CMAC round this was
a CAC round um in the 10-year plan we
were able to um to to fund and bring in
37 uh projects into the 10-year plan um
with the we had $44 million available
funding 28 uh projects were Transit and
active Transportation projects and nine
were EV
applications uh we we also have a
handout um that's included that
summarizes uh that in further detail
also the municipal Bridge solicitation
we have a handout this is that
additional federal funds to to uh
improve Municipal Bridges so we able to
bring 56 local Bridges uh into the
10-year plan uh using uh this program on
page 25 the quter study program this has
been in the 10-year plan for a while um
we had a an implementation plan it
developed PRI uh you know priority
criteria um working through the gaset
process we've identified uh the top 10
priority uh corridors um and those have
been identified and there's a map which
outlines those um and gas it left it up
to us to prioritize uh the order in
which we address those the idea is we
have funding to address about two a year
uh in the plan and uh under on page 26
the transit
programs uh that program represents
about $42 million in the 10-year plan
about $40 million per year primarily
funded through Federal trans Transit
Administration um the funding is
restricted for transit services Capital
operating and planning and it can't be
uh transferred for other uses uh I would
just say again um at the gaset hearings
we heard a lot of comment about the use
of Transit the need for Transit um the
appreciation for the additional funding
in transit um and I would just point out
the map on the side here uh one of the
things that we repeatedly heard uh for
from transit units users and and and the
public was the lack of an East West
Connection um you can go north and south
using Transit but if you wanted to go
from conquered to Portsmith you have to
actually go through
Boston um so that was you know one of
the one of the issues that was was
brought up is the lack of
interconnectivity in the areas um and
and some of those uh some of the holes
that um needed to be filled in the
transit system um on page 27 we talk
uh there's about $346 million programmed
in the 10-year plan about $35 million
per year this is primarily uh uh funded
through uh Federal Aviation and it's a
grant-based program uh funding is
restricted um funding can't be
transferred for other uses and uh New
Hampshire eligible public use air
airports uh typically get a funding of
about 90% federal aid 5% State and 5%
local funds I I mentioned it's
grant-based it's a little bit different
than all the other systems we get money
from Federal Highway and then we develop
a plan to spend it
um Aviation uh Bureau has to create a
plan and then ask for funding so it's a
grant-based plan so they come up with an
improvement plan they they basically
have a a a 10-year plan but they don't
have money associated with it then they
have to go out and apply for those
grants to receive the funding so it's a
little bit different uh little Nuance uh
in how uh FAA uh funds programs uh on
page 28 we talked about the rail program
we do have a uh a rail program amounts
to about $12 million per year $1.2
million per year it's a special railroad
funding it's primary primarily funding
that we receive for the lease agreements
that we have with private rail companies
so we own the rail quar we lease that to
the rail operators the money that we
receive um which is about $1.2 million
per year we use that to reinvest in
maintenance and construction of those
lines to keep them in in good
repair um so that brings us to the the
changes that were made so that o overall
is the program um so what went into the
10-year plan some of the strategies we
used um on page 29 is a list of the
projects um that were changed or or had
a change to them during the gaset
process
um very briefly we talk about the CAC
projects U that were brought
in um the quarter study program that was
brought in uh bringing back Manchester
uh exits 6 and 7
uh within the 10-year plan uh reducing
the delay um on Bo conquered um from
three years to
one the um the Newcastle Causeway
project we heard a lot about that so
what we agreed to do is in the outer
years of the 10-year plan and if you've
seen the flooding that's occurring in
the Hampton area um this was an sort of
their their request of the causeway
floods and they don't have a way off the
island except going over a red listed
Bridge
um so uh this there's a project in the
10-year plan and what we agreed to do
was uh accelerate the the design of that
so that if we ever did get uh any like
resiliency money or protect money we
might be able to advance that project um
there are two Tilton projects um that we
heard about at the Tilton public hearing
uh we were working with those towns
adjusting the scope and adjusting the
descriptions um to be more in line with
what they would they would like
um uh there was a a Bedford project um
it was it was a CT so it didn't qualify
as a bridge the the solution is it's
it's a big Culvert that's just under a
bridge configuration the the answer is a
bridge so we agreed to to put that in
our Municipal Bridge uh uh project so we
added that as a new project
um the Statewide um exit sign ring
project and you have some experience
with that I know there was a house bill
uh last couple weeks talked about that
uh gas it removed that uh that project
uh from the 10-year
plan uh and then there were earmark
project this is more of a scrier error
that those projects uh earmark projects
uh erroneously didn't have inflation we
added inflation to those um on page 30
so those are the changes that were
occurred in the plan through gaset uh on
page 30
was um uh the governor's uh changes the
first five projects were uh CAC projects
um that he uh removed um most of them
you'll see dealt with the EV charging
stations um there was also a Portsmith
uh sidewalk project it the the proposal
was to upgrade a sidewalk to a a 10-
foot wide path
um thought it was sort of a a redundant
project because there was already a path
there um but what he what he suggested
doing what he requested us to do was
take those funds and uh replace them in
in a certain way um so the Hampton
Branch rail trail project is underfunded
he requested that we add $2.5 million
into those projects um to to to help
fully fund those or bring the funding up
um on those because we heard a lot about
uh that project and then um the other
three at the bottom of the list were
Transit related uh projects um that he
would like to see put in some of them
were additional monies for programs um
as well as um a a a a vehicle use um uh
project and and a coast facilities
Improvement project um and finally on
page 31
is a do list of changes you'll see it's
pretty blank um the one projects in
there I talked about the Newcastle
Causeway project and in our great
hesitation when we when we updated and
changed it we took it out of the 10-year
plan so so in the new books you have
it's back in the 10-year plan but we
wanted
to sort of uh fall on our sword and say
we made a mistake we clicked the wrong
button um and it doesn't show in the
10-year plan in the governor's
submission it's now back in the 10year
plan so what this will be used for as
changes are made to the 10year plan um
through do
action this 10year plan you see is
actually a snapshot from six months ago
when we
started we had to do that because it's a
moving living
creature we were working on projects
we're we moved projects we've increased
funding on projects we could not keep
that up in the plan that you see today
so what we do is we take that snapshot
and what you have today we will re
reconcile changes that have been made in
the last six months to reality and we'll
show that in the change log so what goes
uh to the governor for Signature will be
that reconciled copy but we want you to
be aware of we've had projects that were
listed in 24 to advertised for
construction in 2024 that is not in the
10-year plan they've been moved to 2025
that is in the 10-year plan you won't
see it in your plan you'll see it on
that list so those are the type of
things that we're talking about will
show up on this list um as soon as we're
done done here so okay with that that's
the end of our presentation thank you
gentlemen uh representative Jack please
uh thank you Mr chairman uh so just to
be clear everything on these blue Pages
uh you're not asking the you're not
waiting for the committee to amend
anything that's already been
Incorporated those have already been
Incorporated yes okay yes representative
Mills please yeah I got a couple of uh
just and you don't have to go into depth
on this but normally we we I
I've I've had the information during
this presentation um first of all going
back to the pavement and I noticed it's
down to 260 for years I know our our DOT
plan had always been that goal was five
500 miles are Are We Now adjusting it
down is is that or are we still going to
strive for the 500 Miles our goal had
always been 500 Miles the the the
problem is the cost gone up yeah that's
just want make we have the same amount
of money it when the costs go up it
means we paid
less and okay please continue follow up
uh red lless Bridges we will normally
get an update on what the status is I
know you said that you've made trend
tremendous uh improvements on the
bridges due to the extra money and if we
could just for later on don't have to
have numbers now but we'll normally get
a synopsis of we were at 300 Red List
Bridges uh 275 were carried forward and
25 were added and 50 were removed
commissioner Cass that was slide that
was the slide we accidentally yeah and
then um my final one was um and it's
always been concerned to this committee
because we're always active in the
conquered
nashwa Boston Railway Corridor and our
solution so far has been the conquered
Boston bus lines which we would normally
get a a little bit more of an update on
the status of what that is now has has
that service increased has it decreased
I know at one year we went out and
actually funded buses for them so they
could get up and and increase the
schedule and if we could just get a
little recap for that later on and with
that Mr chair that ends my question okay
thank
you Jack uh thank you again uh just I'm
a little fiscal year challenge so this
is the last bium where we have the
367 going to highways and so next bium
we would have to come up with a $20
million replacement plan if we wanted to
continue doing that correct yeah it EXP
Ires our our use of the pavement expires
in
2025 oh yes represent abbit please yes
if you could just go back to page
15 in the
presentation I get what um the approv
funding comes through and my question is
what is the
individual
so an individual project is a a
basically a standalone project that we
we do um um it comes in usually they
come in through the regional Planning
Commission or they could be a red listed
Bridge Project um General Sol well it's
probably a bad example
um uh CRA Campton the lift bridge um
over the the river that's a standalone
project you if you looked in the plan
you'll see cber Campton it's
self-contained self-funded so an
individual project are those projects
that are not part of a programmatic or
mandate
or fit into another program it's a
basically a a self-contained project
under of
itself okay thank you further questions
yes please represent jurly thank you Mr
chairman on page 30 projects uh
44626 in Nasha and
44629 in conid what what the total
amount for those projects total dollar
amounts that uh it's like they were
removed in the
plan I think they were consistently
about $1.8 million most of those were I
I think we're typically that that amount
but we have Checkers in the back of the
room
no yeah we can get we can get you that
definitive
answer thank you further questions
please ref Newman
please thank you again on page 30 um in
the manchest you're removing the project
this would be for Ev dispensers at
Market Basket grocery
stores is anybody aware do any Market
baskets in the state have EV uh stations
at their
places
uh yes I believe they do I think the the
particularly I know the new ones in um
Penacook the new Mark basket there do um
I do believe in um Plymouth as well too
there's a new market basket and stuff
there that they do so a couple of the
projects that they that they did um that
that that these were um removed in the
governance phase they were the these
tended to be outliers they they were the
ones that that uh were more expensive
than than the average uh projects in
there so and I think an attempt to um
better balance some of that that that
program that that um um eliminating some
of the um higher cost EV charging
projects and redirecting some of that
money toward Community Transportation
and the rail trails and active
Transportation
was you kind of the Bal Balancing Act
there yeah thank you thank you
representative faulman please thank you
going back to page 13 want to understand
allocation of
the so-called gas
tax you've accounted for S cents there's
another 15 cents and just we clear that
cents goes to
a is there a firm division of the uh of
the of the highway
fund by splitting that uh or is that
just the way we've programmed
it I I I don't know if I understand your
question I'm looking at funding State
turn by tolls you've got betterment 3
cents sp3 67 4.2 so there's another 15
cents in the gas tax and then there's uh
vehicle registration fees that are on
top of that how are those funds
additional funds accounted for they I
know some of them go to operations a lot
of them go to operations yeah these are
these are the dedicated funds from the
highway from the from the road toll and
the gas tax that go to these these
programs
um uh we have a breakdown we usually
discuss it in depth when we're at the
budget budget phase but most of most of
the gas tax goes to um the operating
costs of Department of Transportation
and Department of of safety these These
are called out because these are
dedicated funds from the gas tax that go
to these specific um um and and
restricted to these specific purposes um
so part of the gas tax goes to um you
know goes to block grant Aid uh some it
then then filters down and goes also to
um Department of Safety and the other
agencies as it's appropriated out of the
um um undesignated Revenue into the
highway fund um we have that in the
budget if if you're interested at at the
work session we can go over over that
for clarity um we have that broken down
quite detailed I'll defer that to them
that thank you okay please go ahead
represent kazinski right thank you thank
you for taking my question kind on the
same
line um am I to believe that 100% of the
gas tax and 100% of the road toll goes
to Transportation expenses
no about 60% goes to Transportation
operating
expenses close to 40% goes also to um
cost of Collections and Department of
Safety and other um other uh other
agencies that are
out of the highway fund does any go in
general fund
no thank you okay that's it okay thank
you for your question further questions
of commissioner Cass and Mr oldenberg uh
I have one gentlemen so in the
presentation it looks like and I this is
a bit 10 years from now but if we don't
do anything with the gas tax revenue or
change our system which we're working on
now then the the 4.2 cents that we
passed 10 years years ago that this
committee recommended we all went along
with in the legislature would that go
away right the gas tax would be reduced
is that correct is I and not the revenue
wouldn't be available for funding
different programs correct on on the
books on on the books right now on the
debt service for the Tiffy loan for i93
is paid off in around
2034 uh the current legislation calls
for that 4.2 cents to Sunset and go
away okay okay for yes represent Jack
please yes but as I asked you rep
following up on that uh it's not
available starting next year because
it's being used to pay the loan so
there's no Highway work there's no
further Highway work being done with
loan that's that that that that portion
of it if you look at that chart in the
waterfall there is still um a percentage
of it that goes to block grant a a
percentage of it that goes to that that
that waterfall goes to state aid Bridge
Bridge um then and then the and then The
Debt Service uh but there is nothing
left afterwards for any typical uh
Paving a bridge or or or betterment type
of uh work but there is there is still
there is still that waterfall that is in
place um as as the as the revenue comes
in so the state a bridge would continue
and and the and the
betterment and there yeah right yes so
if you look at what what sheet was that
on sheet 21
so that's a total revenue say in 2030
say 2026 so this 30 about $34 million of
uh rad toll from that 4.2 cents uh 12%
goes to cities and towns through
Municipal block grant Aid um 2026 about
$23.4 million will go to pay the debt
service and the remaining then goes to
um uh state a bridge for municipal
Bridges but then there is nothing else
uh remaining um beyond that whereas in
been so just just for clarity you are
you are essentially right but I just
wanted to clarify that it does that all
of that 4.2 cents today does not go to
um Highway and Bridge it goes through
that uh waterfall established in the
bill
Sol okay thank you ref Jack commissioner
Cass any further questions okay I'm
going to ask a question and I just want
to be sure you about this there is no
funding for the capital cord or
passenger Rail Project in this plan as
proposed by gas at the governor and do
is that correct that is correct all
right okay good I just want to be
absolutely sure thank you and and I I
would I'll apologize if you saw in the
change log that the gaset recommended
the Capital C or being there as a new
project that was erroneous so there was
an ER that was an eror and the new new
change log uh removed that we we talked
about it because there was discussion it
was a dis it was discussion uh at the
meeting because the public brought it up
during the public hearings it
accidentally got left in as a discussion
point in the change log so we apologize
for that okay all right thank you okay
uh further questions from the committee
yes represent Jack please and following
up just so we get this on the record the
Dot's position is that we could not
continue to the 5309 construction phase
without doing more work on the on the
planning
um what what is 5309 uh that's the the
construction phase uh competitive grant
funding
correct yes yeah we we we had just for
clarity we we had um completed uh all of
the draft documents a draft
environmental impact statement a draft
financial plan um to proceed any any
further would have required some some um
additional um additional work finalizing
the environmental document further
coordination with uh FTA and actually
preparing a a grant
application so um with that said that
that's where we had left it with those
with those draft documents um to to see
where we go from there and followup uh
do we know what the cost of that
additional work might
be uh the additional work to um to
complete like an a a new starts Grant
application yes we had an estimate for
that in our in our in our budget I don't
know what it is off the top of my head
but uh through the work session if
you're interested uh we we do we do we
we had uh we had scoped that out but I
can't I don't know the number off the
top of my head but we can get that for
you all right thank you ref thank you
for being willing to come back and
provide that at a a future work session
okay yes repesent Newman please yes
thank you following up on representative
Jack's question so the amount of work
that has been done on the capital
Corridor but has been put on
hold do you have an amount of that in
other words the cost an estimated cost
stopped yes yes yes I again I'm not
prepared I have that all in another
folder and we can bring that and talk
about it but and and I and and I and I
guess I would also clarify that I don't
know if it's actually been put on hold I
think we fulfilled what we were there
was always a question of of next steps
and and and funding for Grant
application or funding for construction
or or anything to move it move it
forward so um we so I would just uh you
know clarify we we pretty much completed
the scope that we had
identified with the exception of
carrying it forward to the um to the
Grant
application um piece of that but I I do
believe that there was always going to
be a
um a pause as we debated publicly you
know whether to you know where where
where where where where and how that
would be funded
so okay thank you further questions from
the committee about the presentation or
anything else uh relevant to
Transportation yes represent jur one
more briefly uh just going back to page
30 on the um Nashua Manchester and
conquered EV charging those monies were
brought were folded into other efforts
besides charging stations did I hear you
correctly on your answer previously
that's correct and if you look at the
like the change log on the governor's
phase the those those those projects
were which weren't supported the the
funding Associated them was redirected
into uh Community
Transportation um some of the Hampton
Branch rail trail improvements and um um
Transportation demand services so a
little bit more um balancing and
broadening of of the utilization of
those
funds yeah okay thank you any further
questions from the committee of of
commissioner uh Cass and Mr oldenberg
any further
questions I see none so unless you have
something to add gentlemen uh I think
we're done for now and of course uh you
know we'll you'll be here for the public
hearing at one is is that correct and
there will be a public hearing just a
remind of the committee so I think we're
done and we'll journ for lunch sure
enjoy your lunch and please be back at 1
pm for the public hearing can I make one
one sure yes just um U representative
Mills had outlined a few things that we
have typically had in the past so at the
work sessions we'll come prepared to
kind of go over the um you know the um
where we are with the uh Boston express
bus service the um uh red lless Bridges
and a little bit more detailed
discussion about the uh Paving Paving
program and things like that if there
are other areas of interest uh that you
would that that uh you know again the
presentation was fairly broad um if you
if if uh if there were if there was any
specific areas of of of discussion or
further detail that the committee or
committee members would like um you know
we can plan on that on the for the for
the for the work sessions um okay so
we'll go from there we discussed okay
are you all set with that represent
requested a lot of information okay and
representative Newman on the capital
corter right I mean okay that was the
only other thing that I noticed but
anybody else have any other questions
that the department can elaborate on a
future work session all because I want
them do prepared yes representative abot
yes I think it might be helpful to uh
especially the folks that are new to
this committee if um they have some kind
of anagram or whatever that what the
letters stand for in
there
oh all right okay so you're all set
thank you very much for coming in this
thank you we'll see you this afternoon
and for the committee Jour you have uh
lch uh you know for an hour and 10
minutes please be back on time for 1
p.m. for the public hearing very
important yeah I know thank you Mr
you
time being uh 10:3 I would like to open
up the public
hearing uh for House Bill 2024 relative
to the state 10-year Transportation
Improvement plan U before I do I
apologize for the crowding of our room
uh we've been operating in two rooms for
a number of years since Co and we were
fortunate enough to get our own
committee room back but it it doesn't
allow for as much room for people from
the public so I just uh make a apology
for that if uh if you're new to the
process uh and you wish to speak
um we need you to fill out a a pink card
uh and then you can just pass it to one
of the uh Representatives on the end of
the table it get be it'll be brought
forward uh if you happen to be a state
representative I wish you would or a
senator you would note that on here it's
customary that we we take input from
those folks so they can go back to their
committees and we're not seeing that at
this point so um I will will uh bring
forward Colin lent from the Stratford
Commission and I want to welcome you to
Public Works and highways and when
you're ready you go right ahead sir two
minutes thank you chairman Muni and
members of the committee my name is
Colin lent uh I'm a regional
transportation planner with straford
regional Planning Commission and I'm
here on behalf of the 18 municipalities
that comp comprise the the planning
commission's uh area the The Cooperative
lines for C Coast Transportation or
coast and the University of New
Hampshire are also members of the
commission along with state and federal
agencies um the appointed members from
those communities and agency as agencies
asked me to come here to uh speak about
specific projects and and overarching
issues that are related to the 10-year
plan um so specifically on those
projects um I heard there may be
announcement that that might be one of
related to one of these um but the the
projects that are in the current ter
current 10year plan remain priorities
for straford RPC um one of these
includes a a study at New Hampshire 155
in Madbury Road in Madbury uh that's
project
there were two projects submitted to the
draft 10e plan through the regional
Planning Commission process um in
collaboration with municipalities and
prioritized by our uh our Board of
basically our board of directors the
Commissioners um the summersworth
project uh
44260 that's a complete streets project
on their Main Street um uh and that's
that's going to be vital for their
downtown revitalization efforts uh a
project and Lee to uh realign
and uh eliminate some redundancies in
the George Bennett Road and leh Hook
Road we call it just the big triangle uh
project
replacement of four Transit bus buses in
their
Fleet um those are 2008 vintage
biodiesel buses and they're they're
looking to replace those with uh either
CNG or or all electric buses so uh newer
models with more fuel efficiency
um looking at time uh also here um the
the uh Municipal representatives from
our commission also requested more
transparency on why the selected SE ra
projects were removed from the draft
10-year
plan uh last on specific projects uh a
bridge in Durham Bennett Road over the
uh the railroad now owned by CSX uh has
a Timber deck that is not rated for
heavy duty vehicles and it requires
their local uh solid waste removal fire
trucks or emergency response um and and
heavy plows to make a long detour as
there isn't a a nearby road to get over
the the railroad tracks there um so that
um wasteful and inefficient in in the
best case and potentially
life-threatening for their emergency
response um so the current 10-year plan
has construction funds in 2026 the new
draft uh moves that to 2028 and the the
the town is wishing that those funds
could remain in 2026 for
construction um I I'll go very briefly
uh over some of the overarching things
in the handout that I left at at
everyone's place um related to the 10e
year plan uh that the straford re RPC
supports in terms of um keeping the
system performing well and that includes
uh making making sure highway travel is
reliable and supporting investment in uh
more diverse modes modes like public
buses passenger Rail and inner city bus
um keeping up with infrastructure costs
is a a local and national issue I'm sure
you all know um and we're will require
updating our funding mechanisms
climate change is also an increasing
threat to infrastructure and the
livelihoods of New Hampshire residents
and demands increased investment in
adaptation and
mitigation uh safety is an extremely
important issue for our commissioners um
as part of our work we map crashes that
result in fatalities and serious
injuries those dots on a map are people
or were people uh and all too often we
know them personally um our our planning
starts from the policy that zero is the
only except acceptable number of
fatalities and serious injuries on on
Hampshire uh there is increased demand
for public transportation throughout
Southeast New Hampshire um this is
especially true with our uh aging
population for example Coast uh our
regional transit provider along with UNH
uh Coast provides door-to-door service
for people with qualifying disabilities
uh demand for that service has increased
nearly 900% to since 2008
and now represents and that's also a 7
750 increase in coasts costs to provide
that
service uh services like C&J inter city
bus and Amtrak down Easter have since
recovered from the pandemic and provide
a uh provide a vital link to Urban and
economic centers in neighboring Maine
and
Massachusetts last couple of points I'm
probably over time my apologies um just
thinking of economic linkages uh Coast
also operate uh their operations are
responsible for $25.8 million in
economic benefits to the southeast to
Southeast New Hampshire according to a
study that um me and my colleagues at
Rockingham Planning Commission conducted
a couple of years ago uh we heard
directly from restaurant and hotel
owners who told us that they would not
be in Business Without public transit
for their
employees uh last L uh housing
affordability and transportation are
directly linked in the straford region
families are having to travel farther
from employment centers to find housing
that they can afford and I'm not talking
about lowincome housing per se I'm
talking about families with too stable
income uh incomes who are struggling to
find affordable rent let alone by a
house um this also impacts impacts
employers as prospective employees are
driven farther away by Rising housing
costs and public transportation plays a
key role in providing a link between
housing and employment
all of the projects that you spoke of
before you went to your uh handout are
they all mentioned in that handout that
you gave us okay thank you that the the
remarks in the the handout are much
longer than my already for both comments
so sounds good are there are there
questions for the
gentlemen seeing none oh I'm sorry
please thank you Mr chairman and thanks
for taking my question can you tell me
if the ridership and coast and others
has been increasing or decreasing or
staying the same for the past say five
years it has I'll there are folks from
coast who can speak to specific numbers
better than I but the last numbers I saw
that they're back to 80% of their pre
pandemic ridership so it has rebounded
um that's it's still essential for for
employment and um medical trips people
getting to school um and it I think it
re rebounded faster than other services
like like Amtrak and C&J Bus thank you
represent Newton further questions
all next would be uh Michael barot bar
that was pretty close uh from the um
you're representing the town of Durham
welcome sir to public works thank you
I'm Michael Baron the town planner for
the town of Durham um good afternoon Mr
chair members of the committee and um
some old friends from Rochester I'm
pleased to see I will be very quick as
um Colin lent um uh kindly mentioned
there's just um the one one item in the
tenear plan that I would encourage you
to just take another look at a a detail
um the there's a the Bennett Road Bridge
in dur is a um crosses O is a key road
and it crosses over uh a rail a railroad
and um this is a maximum of 10 tons
which does not allow most of our uh
major public works equipment plow trucks
fire trucks our Solid Waste trucks and
as Colin said it's it's really an issue
of wastefulness and inefficiency and
potentially a safety issue because it it
really affects our response time to a
significant uh part part of the town and
um originally this was scheduled for
construction in 20
2026 and that has been at the moment
pushed back two years to
2028 so I would simply um request and
urge you if at all possible to move the
construction date back two years to the
original
2026 thank you um I have a question if I
could are there are there any um town
City funds involved in that project no
it is um it's um 8020 um with the
federal and state government but nothing
from the town okay thank you any further
questions for the
you I would like to recognize Terry
manager
for my representatives from Rochester
being referred to as older are we okay
comment thank you welcome please
introduce yourself Terry sure my name is
Terry Palmer I'm the Statewide Mobility
manager for the State of New Hampshire
um thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm kind of new to this so
please pardon my nervousness um I just
wanted to take a few minutes of your
time and explain to you what the
mobility manager network has been able
to accomplish in just the past two years
we were lucky enough to receive funding
with um our CDC DHHS partners and uh
they helped to implement the mobility
manager Network in the state of New
Hampshire so now we have eight Regional
Mobility managers and myself as the
State Mobility manager so every part of
the state is is uh covered with a
Mobility manager they work very closely
with their Regional coordinating
councils and the regional planning
commissions um what mainly what we do is
we help find Transportation options for
the residents of New Hampshire um and
these Transportation options as you all
know there's there are many gaps within
the state of New Hampshire what we try
to do is find the best option for that
person um it could be public
transportation it could be a volunteer
driver program maybe the the resident
has PTSD and can't use public transit or
maybe P public transit just isn't um in
their area so we do a lot of that we
also reach out to a lot of our partners
and stakeholders and we try and fill
those gaps in
transportation um in the past two years
we probably have gone to over a thousand
Outreach events within the state um I
work with State stakeholders with
Department of Health and Human Services
Department of Education veteran services
and we try and fill those gaps in
transportation um so thank you very much
for the additional funding that you've
been able to give the transportation
resources because with the additional
funding we are able to expand
Services um and that's just helping the
residents in the state of New Hampshire
so I feel like I have a lot more I want
to say but right now it's just uh I
can't find the words so no thank you um
and for a lady that said she was nervous
she did perfectly fine thank you very
much um may I may do you have any
written testimony you could uh email or
share or send to the committee
explaining your program yes if you could
that would be very helpful yep any any
other questions for M Palmer yes
represent B thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for your te testimony Miss
Palmer um can you just briefly talk
about some of your challenges as
administrator as it relates to Coos
Carol Grafton and Sullivan County which
I imagine become very problematic with
the limited limited options regarding
Transportation as opposed to to places
like Hillsboro Strafford Rockingham
marac where there a little bit there's a
little bit more diversity and more
population to make accommodations
absolutely um um and based on on what
you just mentioned too we have a lot of
rural areas in those areas that you just
mentioned as well so um in fact we've
been working on trying to find
transportation for where uh New
Hampshire so um in the North country you
know um it's they are very diverse and
in the way where they don't feel that
they they need Transportation so when we
do Outreach events and when we go to
senior centers and we talk to them about
Transportation options that we could
possibly bring into the area they're
kind of like oh that's that's really
cool um but they're not
really it's it's hard because right now
like Tri count Transit they're waiting
on buses they can't hire drivers without
buses they can't expand without funding
so once they do start to expand and they
are able to bring Transportation options
into the area I think you're going to
see a lot more people using public
transit um it is very difficult when you
don't have taxi services volunteer
driver programs or anything to really
show the benefit of Transportation in
those areas um we have been working with
the Sullivan County right now with um
they've got some great things going on
with their Amtrak airport uh their
airports being renovated so we're
talking to them about Transportation
back and forth to the airport so these
are all conversations that continue day
in and day out so we've got some
Transportation projects happening in the
manad region they're looking at a
different Transportation model so that
way they can expand
Transportation um we're talking to folks
in the Plymouth area to see what we can
do in to do there um yeah so there's
there's a lot going on so thank you very
much for the funding to keep this where
it going thank you he further questions
yes please thank you Mr chair Tim jurus
did do you does the system offer
individual rides from from from singular
addresses as well as you know a typical
bus or van or a shuttle yep so what the
mobility manager network does is we're
not actually an agency we're not a
transportation agency we work very
closely with all of our providers we um
all of the mobility managers know all
the transportation options whether
they're for-profit nonprofit and they
will find the best resource for them
them um the the mobility managers do
great if they're going from one region
to another region or if they if they
have uh Transportation needs outside of
the state they they know about all the
you know Dartmouth Coach and and so on
and so forth so they they work amongst
themselves to find the best
transportation
option yes represent vone thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question um obviously there's a need and
you're you're trying to fulfill um in
your your written comments to us do you
include kind of a data piece in regards
to what the needs are based by you know
region by demographics and so on do we
are we going to get something to look at
that just so we can kind of gauge how
what kind of resource you know are we
matching the resources with the need
absolutely so you're looking for where
we already cover transportation and
where the gaps
are yeah that would I think in terms of
matching services to need but also I
mean I don't know if you've got that
kind of information or or anyone's
providing that just in terms of like how
many people are sitting out there and
they're not going places because you
know they've they've got hospital visits
to go or they've got they have
appointments to go
to what how what's the the depth of the
need and I don't know if that study has
been done or or what you might have but
that would be something that would would
definitely help to inform decisionmakers
like us uh as to what kind of resources
should be going that direction well
thank you very much for bringing that up
there's actually uh we are waiting for
funding to come through for our needs
assessment um and with that needs
assessment that will give us the data
that we're looking for as far as you
know where are the gaps what are what
are uh residents wanting do they want
another volunteer driver program do they
want microtransit do they want public
transit um you know so yes if if you
happen to see or hear any of the the
needs assessment talk um we definitely
need that to to to move
forward yeah followup so that and that's
great because I think that's just the
kind of information that we would could
so do you have a timeline as to when
that needs assessment or are you you're
waiting on the money so that you can
actually do it
right yeah I think Steve's gonna speak
to that in just a little bit so great
okay well I'm looking forward to it
thank you okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman any further
questions seeing none thank you thank
for your testimony uh we will bring up
Steve is it Workman yes
Hampshire good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you very
much uh for allowing me to talk with you
this afternoon uh my name is Steve
Workman and I'm the director of
Transport New Hampshire I also serve on
the leadership team as treasur for the
Statewide um Community SEC so the state
coord ordinating Council for Community
Transportation so I think I want to
deviate because the subject of the needs
assessment came up so let me just tackle
that now so it doesn't get lost so as my
colleague Terry said um we do have a
plan uh it's a proposal that we uh
submitted to the governor's office
specifically through Gopher for the arpa
funds and we submitted that uh two years
ago this coming August and at the time
as you probably are aware the governor's
office and gopher have been working
through the state's priorities and how
to effectively use that money so at this
point in time that has remained in the
mix um recently in December the governor
was able to connect with a lot of uh
constituents uh who spoke about the need
and how they can't get to basic Services
basic social uh outings and this really
drove the point home that I think you
were getting at uh
representative in that he saw that there
is an unmet need out there and the light
bulb went off in his head that on the
corner of his desk is a proposal to do
this so This Statewide needs assessment
would be arpa funded if we're successful
and it would engage our regional
planning commissions our Mobility
management Network um we're hoping to
engage New Hampshire fiscal policy
Institute UNH Survey Center to do a
comprehensive look the first of its kind
for the entire State because I think the
point that you were trying to make is if
we don't have real data we are Flying
Blind and so where is the actual um
Strategic investment and what we're
doing giving we don't have endless
amounts of funds so definitely any
leverage to help us get across that we
think that'll be about a 12-month
process but we feel like we will come
back with solid Baseline data not just
the anecdotal stories which are
important so I'll move on unless
somebody wants to speak to that right
now why don't why don't we we have a lot
of people to speak yeah that's what I
fig so I want to suggest in in my job I
U I work in the spaces in between I
don't do any direct service so I'm
working with State agencies our
providers in the transportation World
providers in healthare you name it local
government County government and the
federal government and what I try to do
is find ways to bring people together so
that we can find common Solutions and
shared resources to address some of the
most vexing problems that actually go
across all of our state agencies I it's
no surprise to all of you that we often
have to operate in a silo because
there's just so much work to do the
problem is that comes with a cost it
means we're missing opportunities if you
go back to the federal level you're
going to see that the federal government
has made changes through something
called the coordinating Council on
access and Mobility this is under FTA
but it brings together federal agencies
who all have a portion of transportation
services and what it's doing is trying
to remove the barriers in policy level
that prevent us from doing what we know
would work and also to increase funding
but to encourage from the top down that
these agencies are working together gone
Goes The Silo sure you have requirements
but this is going to lead to a more
effective use of this so when you look
at the 10-year plan that's in front of
you I want to suggest that you're not
actually just passing a plan I mean
technically you are but what I want to
suggest is you're actually creating the
environment for this to thrive we have
taken the Investments which you have
provided to us both in the budget last
year as a bipartisan and increase um the
money that Terry mentioned which was
part of a federal covid disparity Grant
we use $3 million to build our capacity
those Grant funds and that project ends
in may we have built the capacity and I
feel that my colleagues and I have
demonstrated that with an investment on
your part we are able to do the
groundwork so that we can address the
North Country which has very specific
issues the large geography makes it hard
to compare that with our more urban
centers where there are more population
we know things are different in New
Hampshire so you're going to create that
that environment and let's remember what
the investment and transportation in
total is doing it is providing a boost
to our economy we know that that
transportation is literally the
circulatory system for most everything
we do so this is an opportunity to make
sure that we can get people to work and
citizens into those businesses to buy
the goods and services that they need we
also know that transportation is at the
center of Housing and that is a high
priority right now for this state we
know that health care we have a problem
with missed appointments or simply I
can't schedule it because I can't get
there and so in that environment we have
physical health mental health but then
there's something else we've brought
into our transportation discussion and
that's called social determinants of
health or vital conditions this is what
makes our our communities Thrive and
it's what allows individuals to age in
place and to meet the basic needs that
they do we understand that social
determents of Health social activities
are critical for older adults isolation
is a leading cause of death or a
decrease in aptitude and ability level
these are things that we want to be at
the table with all of you and our
partners to fix and we feel that when
you make an investment in the 10-year
plan and in the budget process to
support us we can do good things with
that so I'll close my thoughts by just
saying if you can continue to support
work with us provide us the finances we
promise you we will work on the data and
we are ready to come to the table with
you your constituents or anyone else to
solve those problems in the different
sectors that we've talked about so with
that thank you for the time thank you Mr
Workman uh a question number one do you
have any written testimony you can leave
with the clerk or email us I do so that
we have your comments and are you a
project number in the 10year plan I am
not a project number okay thank you are
there further questions for the
gentlemen seeing none thank you sir
thank
you um Mr Nicholls from uh coast and is
it
[Music]
sir
sorry today's one of those days my body
does not like me so I I understand days
like that sir go right
ahead uh good afternoon thank you Mr
chair members of the committee my name
is rad Nichols I'm the executive
director for Coast uh also known as
Cooperative Alliance for Sea Coast
transportation we are the public transit
provider for the greater seos region
we're also the home
for uh both for fiscal home and uh staff
for the regional coordination Council in
our part of the state and the regional
Mobility manager uh that's called act or
the alliance for Community
Transportation I uh I'm also the chair
of the New Hampshire Transit Association
I sit on the Statewide
uh
uh coordinating Council for Community
Transportation thank you and I'm also on
the New Hampshire Transportation Council
uh a seat that uh I serve on at the
pleasure or the governor I've submitted
written testimony through the portal
this morning that uh is quite a bit
broader than what I wanted to talk about
today which is really the economic
impacts of public transportation and
Community
Transportation um public and Community
Transportation oper access to
opportunity which which uh drives the
economy and supports communities uh when
New Hampshire residents can access jobs
education and the services they need to
succeed they make a positive
contribution to their communities into
to the state economy yet transportation
is often the missing missing link um
public and Community Transportation
providers connect people and their
Community serving as vital partners for
business Education Health Care and
Social Services across the state public
and Community transportation's Statewide
economic impact is estimated in excess
of $95 million annually uh for every $1
uh invested in public and Community
Transportation the estimated uh effects
on on the E on economic activity are are
$4 so it's a 4 to1 return an investment
in our work is an investment in the
economic growth and competitiveness of
New Hampshire's local Regional and
Statewide
economies State uh investment in public
transportation unlocks at least a
onetoone federal match uh via the
bipartisan infrastructure law or the iig
and up to 4 to one if uh funding is is
allowed to be used uh for any eligible
Federal Transit Administration operating
expense so it has uh very it's very
powerful uh what state funding can do
for us for small urban and rural areas
with public and Community Transportation
in New Hampshire these areas are quite
successful uh and um are providing high
quality and highly sought Services as
Transportation providers we're doing the
very best we can with relatively limited
resources that we have but we could do
so much more um in the last year uh New
Hampshire dot leadership uh leaders in
the executive Council house senate our
counties cities towns and now the
governor's office through his
transmittal letter of the 10-year plan
have been actively advocating for higher
investments in public and Community
Transportation the funding increases
secured this bium while not what the the
uh New Hampshire Transit Association and
our members had requested were
unprecedented
um we are incredibly thankful for that
support and know that this will result
in tens of thousands of additional hours
of service hundreds of thousands of
miles and hundreds of thousands of
additional
rides um so there are there very
positive consequences as a result of
that
investment um I I will say though
there's there's at least one uh public
transit related project uh that did not
Advance uh in the 10-year plan coming
out of the governor's office that's
unh's project uh it's quite unfortunate
that because it is a a very worthy
public transit project uh that uh was
removed um I'll close with the realities
we face as providers uh primarily a
shifting uh Federal funding landscape
and inflation means that without
additional investments in our systems
and our our networks uh we will not be
able to continue to provide the level of
services that we have today um we ask
that the state of New Hampshire play a
growing role in how we fund uh public
and Community Transportation across the
state and we thank the department the
executive counselor and governor for the
increased support contained in the
10-year plan as submitted to you with
that I'll close my remarks thank you
thank you Mr Nichols questions from the
committee yes representative thank you
Mr chairman U as I'm going to refine
this question
that I asked Terry earlier does Coast
provide par transit to to people who
have a Mobility challenged or have
issues difficulty getting to stops
absolutely sir we have about
uh five to seven different programs
available for primarily for older adults
and individuals with disabilities uh
they they they run the Gambit in terms
of purpose some are required under the
Americans with Disabilities Act others
are a result of Partners or communities
wanting more for their Community uh and
uh they have a variety of uh limitations
in terms of trip purpose or number of
times you can ride to to no restriction
we do about 24,000 rides a year
specifically in that area a lot of those
folks can also ride our fixed rout bus
system as well gotta thank you thank you
further
please and thank you for taking my uh
question so you referenced a a project
in the plan do you know what the what
the project name or number
is uh so my comments are are more
General in nature uh regarding uh State
support for public transit Coast has
probably two or three projects in the
plan uh that we we are happy with uh and
then there's program programmatics in
the plan that uh are largely dictated by
federal funding coming into the state so
we're we're we're in support of of the
plan as it sits thank you thank you um
if if I could for the representative UNH
has a representative that's going to
speak so perhaps they could shed some
light to that if not we can ask we can
ask the department thank you thank you
for your testimony sir thank you like to
recognize um
Katherine
emis please come forward have a seat
welcome to Public Works representing U
Wentworth by the Sea homeowners
association yes um I'm a my name is
Katherine eams I'm a resident of
Newcastle and I'm on the homeowners
association board for the Wentworth by
the Sea uh
development the uh the I'm speaking
specifically to the 1B Causeway uh
section of the plan um there are two
ways to get on and off the island or the
islands known as Newcastle one of them
is the causeway which seems to get quite
you know quite a bit of press That's
What goes along into into Portsmouth the
other side is um there's a drawbridge
between Newcastle and rye and uh on the
Rye side of the uh of Wentworth road
which is 1B there is a significant dip
in the road
uh to the point where that was shut down
both the sto by the storms in December
the storm right before Christmas and uh
traffic was not allowed through there in
either of the January
storms so my question is that there are
two Jetties one from Odon Point State
Park and one from Fort Stark that are by
definition of a jetty are supposed to
provide
um a a leveling or an evening of the
waves and the and the tides that come in
and out of Little Harbor so last
Saturday when the astronomical High
Tides were um were uh uh what's the word
in play um that I walked over to the
bridge and walked over to that dip I
could not see either of the Jetties the
water was coming
over those Jetties to the point where
there was there was almost no Ripple
even the water was coming so high over
those Jetties so my question is does the
1B project um in any way address the
Jetties because at least my
understanding is I'm not a scientist I'm
I'm a homeowner um but my understanding
is that the Jetties will do a lot
to help the inflow and outflow and the
rate of it so that we won't have the
ponding issue that exists on 1B and I
just am not I haven't I have don't
understand enough to know whether the
Jetties are being um considered or any
if if they're even U you know how often
the an engineer goes out and takes a
look at them or anything I I that's
really my question um I I thank you for
that I my my first response is well
number one thank you for being here
uh number two the um have you spoken to
the department about this or are you
bringing this issue first to us it um it
was raised um at um Janet Stevens um
Regional meetings that were held um last
fall and um there was there was concern
because the where the dip is is is
private property one side it's the
Wentworth by the SE Wentworth Country
Club and the other side are our
homeowners and so uh um but that clearly
would be an issue um that if there is
going to be the causeway worked on if
the dip on the other side isn't
addressed we still may have issues in
terms of access on and off thank you do
you have written testimony requesting a
response from us uh no why don't you go
ahead and follow up with that and okay
send it through U general court public
works and uh send it to myself as a
chairman I appreciate cannot promise you
anything but we we will we will ask the
question wonderful thank you very much
dairy good
afternoon um I'm Jeff Molen I'm
professional engineer I volunteer for
the town of dairy as a representative
into Southern New Hampshire Planning
Commission as well as the chair of the
energy Committee in town thank you
welcome thank
you um last fall the New Hampshire do
decided to modify the state's 10year
plan to include some electric vehicle
charging
stations um via Federal CAC
funding uh the list of projects was
recently modified and approved by
governor
cunu and in addition the Bill H HB 2024
has been introduced here for
approval in the attached list of
projects for the 10-year plan it
included 10 electric vehicle charging
station projects of which eight are for
commercial use supermarkets gas stations
plus two municipal
projects the list also shows projects
not approved which includes includes a
dairy Municipal project for about a $1
million applications for electric
vehicle charging stations CMAC fundings
were requested in the first quarter of
last year via the
DOT der's first application in January
was for 1.5 million which do then
requested to be modified in February
2023 to remove any electric
vehicles all right application was
resubmitted in March to dot with the
vehicles removed for a total project
cost of about $1
million from the list of projects in the
10year plan New Hampshire do used the
wrong submission to eliminate Dairy from
funding theot claims that they were we
were eliminated because we included
electric vehicle
funding we had contacted do to correct
their analysis but did not re receive a
response until January 19th
2024 in which they conceded that they
used the wrong submission from
Derry uh dot directed der to address
this Omission via the legislative branch
which we are doing
today in summary Not only was Derry
improperly disqualified using the wrong
submission but as you can see from the
list preference has been given to
commercial projects versus
municipal we strongly believe that tax
dollars spent should be prioritized
toward direct benefit to the taxpayers
that being Municipal projects versus
subsidizing commercial projects that may
or may not
fail uh this testimony is along along
with the list of projects was submitted
electronically last
week thank you Mr Paul if if I could ask
a question on the committee so tell me
uh I understand the commercial the um
the stores the gas uh and I believe you
said there were two municipal that were
approved in the package 8 and2 what what
are the what's the scope of these
Municipal Chargers that were not put in
they're similar to the uh commercial
projects it's a mix of uh high-speed
charging uh stations as well as level
two well I understand that sir but where
where were you looking to have
those let's see and gorm no I take that
back are they I'm just trying to get a
feel for are these Town Offices maybe
you could categorize them for me the
ones that we are requesting yes the
additional ones yeah these are three
locations within Dairy one is at the
Public Works location which is near
93 the other one is at the U um
municipal building which is right near
downtown less than a mile from exit 4
and then the other one is near the
police station which is going to be
probably a half mile within the new exit
4A okay thank you further questions
represent Faulkner thank you for taking
the question clarify for me the these
charging stations to qualify for funds
do they need to be open to the general
public or are they for the use of the
employees or whatever of the sporing
organization so the intent for the town
of dairy is to introduce electric
vehicles into their Fleet at at their
expense over time as electric vehicles
are suitable for Town
uses um so
that um the money here would be used to
to develop the infrastructure to support
our own electric vehicle Fleet but the
uh the stations were intended to VI used
for Town usage but they could be open
for public If U if there was is a demand
for
it thank you further
questions sir thank you for your time
thank
you uh Bill
Janelle welcome back to Public
unh
so good afternoon uh chairman makoni and
members of the public works and highways
committee my name is Bill Janelle I'm
the associate vice president of
facilities and operations at UNH uh and
I appreciate the opportunity to testify
this
afternoon um so just a little background
so the University of New Hampshire
Durham submitted three projects in n in
Do's 2223 CMAC round and as you know
know uh this program provides 80%
Federal support and has been used
extensively by UNH over the past two
decades to fund essential Transit and
transportation infrastructure projects
on campus which improved air quality and
uh reduce traffic congestion in SE Co
region one thing that may not be um
evident to to everybody but um so UNH
operates one of the largest Transit
agencies in the state U but we're unique
in that we don't receive formula funds
from the federal trans Administration so
our system oper system operations are
funded by a student transportation fee
and campus General funds and therefore
UNH relies heavily on programs like
CAC um for Capital assistance mainly
replacement of buses um and so CAC and
other competitive Transit Capital
programs like it are essential for our
continued operations of the the UNH
transit
system so in this round un had um three
projects that were uh that were proposed
so the first and our highest priority
was the UNH Transit Fleet replacement
project that was for $3.8
million um and it was intended to
replace four
buses and we had initially planned for
uh those buses to be two CG buses and
two electric
buses um second project was a
intersection Improvement project so it
was at the intersection of 155a Main and
Mass road so that's the main entrance to
UNH coming into campus and uh that's a
$1.2 million project it's still in the
plan we very much appreciate that and I
believe it's been Advanced a bit as well
so very appreciative for that and the
third project was a a dur was a com
combination of Durham and UNH it was a
public EV charging station project for
$375,000 and it was for four locations
in in downtown Durham and on
campus so you un we're very pleased that
all three projects were recommended
through the CAC round and included in
the dot draft of the 10-year plan but
unfortunately two of the three projects
so the transit Fleet replacement project
and the EV charging project were dropped
from the governance final
proposal so we're here to request uh
restoration of the UNH Transit Fleet
funding project which is critical to uh
continued reliable operation of our
extensive Transit Transit Network and we
appreciate the support from straford
Regional and also Coast on this project
um and the town of Durham I believe has
written testimony um but this request
would support replacement of four 15y
old full-size transit buses uh so these
buses have over 300,000 miles on them
and they're well beyond their useful
life um the transit consist uh system it
consists of the Durham Campus Connector
which is mainly in the Durham area
uh and also our regional Wildcat Transit
routes which connect Portsmouth and do
and the system provides over half a
million passenger trips annually in the
Sea Coast region the failure of one of
one or more of these vehicles impacts
reliability and operational cost lacking
the capital fund funding support uh
reflected in this request the UN transit
system faces fiscal challenges which
will reduce access to our campus so we
urge the committee to support the
University's request to protect the
operations of our Transit Fleet by
restoring support for these four
vehicles so I just want to talk a little
bit about um a little bit about the
history and sustainability and what UNH
has tried to do in the past so for 25
years UNH has had a thoughtful cost
effective and successful introduction of
clean low emission fuel to our Fleet so
this started with uh B um with B20
biodiesel in 20 000 we then transitioned
to natural gas in 2004 and today the
majority of our Fleet is is powered by
natural gas so um long-term transitions
uh for those two alternate fuels and in
23 we were beginning the planning for an
expected again 20-year Transit Fleet
transition to electric
power and we'd plan to use electricity
from unh's landfill gas so we are a bit
unique in that we generate our own
electricity um and the thought was these
vehicles would be powered would be
charged off peak times and then used uh
during the day and there's also
additional benefits whereas an electric
bus is a large battery and um it could
be used for Emergency Operations if
there was power outages or things like
this
um however um with all that said we
realized there could be concerns with EV
vehicles and that it's too early to down
that road and we understand that and uh
we are quite fine foregoing that uh
transition at this time and looking at
it at a at a future date and um
switching those EVS to CG buses I mean
the bottom line is we just need buses to
run the system and uh that's That's the
basis of the request and that's our
priority in coming here today and
speaking to you thank you Mr Janelle
before I open would you uh be able to
provide for the
the number of uh buses in your Fleet at
another
time um and uh then break that out by
what's still out there for
biodiesel and the um Natural Gas and
Electric and if I could TR you one more
item sure tell me what the replacement
cost is for each one of those items yes
and if you can just forward that to the
committee that would be helpful and is
biodiesel still a
viable uh product that meets your
emission
goals yes or at least the emission
standards that's yes I mean we continue
to use biodiesel in in our diesel buses
today that would be that would be
extremely helpful if you could forward
that other questions from Mr Janelle I
should be back okay sorry thank you so
you B sham
Newton thank you Mr shamman thank you
for taking my question um I'm glad you
brought up that issue about the EVs and
maybe willing to hold back on them
because we've heard repeatedly that
there's a lot of issues with fires and
dependability have you let that be known
because what I saw here was you wanted
four buses two EVs and two of the
regulars so have you let that been known
to anybody that you'd be happy with four
of the uh efficient buses that don't
don't necessarily have to be EV
uh other than at this committee no I
mean we didn't testify when the 10-year
plan came to Durham to that effect um so
I would say no not then not other than
to this committee followup question yes
followup sir thank you um is there is
ridership down I happen to go through I
I live near UNH anyway and I happen to
go through this fall and boy there was a
lot of electric scooters a lot of people
using those now I didn't expect to see
as many as I did is ridership down with
the buses as a result of that or is it
staying about the same ridership is
actually up about 26% from last year oh
good I mean it did take a significant
dip during covid obviously but um we are
we are catching up to get back where we
were and again from last year it's up
26% thank you thank you please represent
jurus thank you Mr chairman regards to
the proposed electric uh the battery
buses will you was you and planning on
installing their own charges for the um
for those buses yes that would be again
I mean this is a our first transition
into this so this would have to be
studied uh to determine you know what's
the right bus what's the size bus what's
the location for the Chargers but we we
were planning a dedicated bus charging
station um for these EV buses yes which
was separate from there was a EV
charging project as well um which would
be more focused on visitors coming to
campus thank you you any other qu yes
repres representative Boyd and then
fauler thank you Mr chairman I
appreciate it Mr CH all thank you very
much for your testimony question
regarding a letter on the Durham UNH
public EV charging at a cost of
$375,000 was there any discussion
between the municipality UNH on Cross
collaborating budgets to be able to fund
that yourselves independently of the
application process um certainly cross
collaboration with un it was a joint um
application with with UNH and Durham uh
as far as funding it ourselves I don't I
don't believe we've uh we've gone down
that road yet we've tried to to find
federal funds or CAC funds to move this
forward thank you very much thank you Mr
represent partner thank
you in terms of EV buses are there
manufacturers in the US EV
buses yes it's my understanding there
are there's uh I believe there's an EV
bus in nashwa and certainly many in
other states please follow up and you
aware of any experience with the EV
buses elsewhere in the world and in fact
aren't there thousands of them in
Europe I'm sorry isn't there a lot of
experience with EV buses in Europe is
that something that you've looked at not
myself personally again I mean I I I
won't claim that EV buses are my
expertise um but we would certainly
investigate that prior to buying
them thank you further further questions
please yes thank you for taking my
question says that um we have funding
from a student transportation fee in J
in campus General funds so what
percentage of your total outlay is
covered by those
charges
uh I mean in a grant like this we would
cover 20% through those fees but you're
talking about the overall budget for the
transit system yeah I'm kind of uh
follow up go ahead represent kind of
thinking on you know is it possible that
maybe you could charge enough and buy
your own
buses or how much of
the this money comes in is a substantial
amount enough to yeah I mean I guess
what I can say is that um between
tuition and fees we are very restricted
um to to the increases that we can um
put forward or absorb um and that's why
we're always looking for opportunities
like CMAC or other Grant programs where
we can get assistance with with
infrastructure thank you for that um
quickly thank you representative thank
you Mr chairman these fullsize buses or
Shuttle type these are fullsize buses
thank you before we do I I must say when
I traveled to Dober and other places the
amount of students that uh occupy these
buses and perhaps we could change the
schedule they end up at my sushi
restaurant when I'm there and uh trying
to get a seat is is very successful so
your collaboration with Coast or
whatever is is a wonderful thing we
thank you for your testimon thank you
all like to hear from um I believe
believe it's Randy Byron is that I'm
sorry what is it sir Brian Brian please
come forward sir two
minutes thank you I'm a Randy Bryan
resident of Newcastle I happen to be on
the energy committee but not the head of
it um but I have been uh my wife and I
have been residents of Newcastle like so
many others for a number of years and my
wife's case decades and uh uh it is a
community that
is I say 80% seniors so it's there's a
large uh uh population that are aging in
place and safety is a concern and we've
had several in the last year I'll say 14
months we've had three or four what I'll
call 15 or 50y year event 20 or 50 year
weather events
uh tide events that have shut off the
island or nearly shut off the island
from from blocking the causeway and the
access through
Rye uh from any uh from any off Island
activity for you know hours at a time so
um it is a I'm just here to re I've
submitted uh previous testimony in the
uh in the hearings organ ized by Janet
Stevens so I don't didn't want to
belabor the same thing now but since
then we've had two events where the uh
Causeway has either flooded or nearly
flooded and you know just last week
there was a after actually and I didn't
even check yesterday with the
astronomical tide yesterday but we've
had um Tides either covering the
causeway or coming within a couple of
inches of the surface and as any any uh
Road engineer can tell you that's
probably not very good for the road bed
so we are uh uh I just want to I just
came here to represent a whole bunch of
friends who want to express our interest
in having the causeway route 1B I'll say
which is a long R not just the causeway
but but to ensure that uh Coast route
access in the in the low-lying areas is
addressed uh all the way from South
Portsmouth all the way around along on
the causeway onto the island and then
off Island into uh into the Ry side um
where it dips just past the you know
between the the bridge and Wentworth
Country Club and then it also dips again
down around BG's Boat House area uh
there's a there's a long path there that
needs to be looked at very very
seriously and very soon because uh you
know we've had three or four I'll say 15
20 uh 50y Year events weather events or
flooding events happen in the last year
and so I see uh uh I've been looking at
this for a very long time and and I in
in my humble opinion
anecdotally uh global warming and and
sea level rising and weather events
appear to be accelerating not just
increasing but
accelerating and uh I think it really
deserves to to remain
however whatever scrutiny is applied to
the to the 10-year plan post this
meeting I believe that this this project
needs to has some some big safety issues
that go along with it thank you Mr Brian
are there questions for the
gentlemen yes
please thank you and thank you for
taking my question it's going to be a
short question do you feel you folks in
Newcastle been ignored by the
do with your
concerns I'm not in in a position to say
that I can say personally and in
conversation anecdotally uh in
conversations with friends and others I
do not believe that we have been from a
roadway
perspective um ignored I would say that
uh uh the concern about the general
acknowledgement and concern about sea
level rising and an its effect on access
to and from the island is a fairly
recent origin start start really
solidified really about a year ago when
we had the first flooding event uh on
Route 1B and
um uh and and it has suddenly made
everybody I mean there are those who
were aware and concerned ahead of time
but it now made everybody aware on the
island it is almost to a person on the
island that they have a concern about uh
about the uh uh the flooding the effect
of flooding on on access to and from the
island thank
you seeing no further questions thank
you sir for coming to Public Works and
and uh your friends thank you for
you um Cindy
yansy uh from conquered Area
Transit Regional three of Community
Transportation please come forward
welcome
thank you very much for allowing me to
speak today I am before you start I
loved five minutes or less that was we
don't see that tag very often keep up
that energy go right ahead just wanted a
few moments of your time just to support
the uh the 10-year plan and uh my my
role here is I'm a regional Mobility
manager I'm one of those Mobility
managers here in New Hampshire I've been
our particular region is all of bnap
County uh marac County except for hooks
it and three towns in Hillsboro County
we have hillsbor daring and Windsor and
I wanted to um just to lay out where I'm
coming from so uh before coming here
today I did speak with Terry page who is
the trans the transportation director of
conquered Area Transit so she runs the
transportation system here in conquered
and along with that uh she also runs a a
program called Midstate Transit which is
a senior and those with disabilities
transportation service throughout that
entire region and with a volunteer
driver program as well so we have Region
3 is doing a it has a a lot of programs
for
transportation um and she has struggled
in the past of course with with funding
and uh I I I just wanted to hit her up a
little bit to see how this funding will
impact her going forward and one of the
so she mentioned three things in
particular she said absolutely it's
going to impact her um wages for drivers
has has historically been low at that uh
agency and she's been able to give her
drivers an increase a ra wage increase
which has allowed her to actually um get
more drivers on she was struggling
filling those roles uh the second part
was that she was actually able to keep
all of the services running which is
really great we don't want to lose any
of the services and uh the third piece
is she said going forward looking
forward if this passes uh she's going
to be able to continue the service that
we have one of the I not sure if those
are aware but we have a brand new route
that she has just started called the
conquered lonia connector we now have a
commuter route that runs from conquered
to lonia Monday through Friday daily it
just kicked off last month and all of
the I've been out promoting that service
uh all along the Route and we're getting
fabulous feedback we're still working on
promoting that service getting the word
out that it's there and some places
we're even having a hard time getting
the bus stops in uh but I just this is
that's a huge for New Hampshire to have
this route that's in place now and she's
going to be able to she with this
funding if this does pass uh the funding
that's in there she's going to be able
to use that as match money for the
federal money so she can assure that
that route can continue and possibly
expand one more little piece is just to
give you some background on some of the
things that a Mobility manager has been
able to accomplish um in the i' it's
almost four years five years that I've
been at in this role um during covid
when the governor had to shut down
services and keep that uh stay-at-home
order we were able to put into place a
shopping for seniors program using
volunteers that would do the shopping
for our seniors that was something that
that we just we had to do on the fly at
the and a Mobility manager was able to
do that I went back and talked to the
transportation director afterwards and
she said you kept our buses running you
kept these people employed that's what
this program really meant along with the
fact that these seniors who were no
longer able to get their groceries they
were able to stay at home as the
governor had asked it with with with
these um the other thing that uh a
Mobility manager has been able to do is
uh we put in for some funding to Rebrand
the concrete Area Transit and the
Mid-State Transit programs that was a a
pro a federal program um and we we
applied for the grant and uh this is
something it was it was all extra work
that a the the
transit staff would not be able to
accomplish it just took too much work
but having a Mobility manager in place
we were able to to do that to get all
that work done to Rebrand their their
program and I did bring some brochures
of the uh conquered Area Transit which
includes the new conquered lonia
connector if anyone would like one I'd
love to leave some here for you so that
we can continue to promote that and with
that I just uh thank you for your time
thank you thank you are there questions
M
shansky um yes representative thank you
Mr chairman the the new route the
connector from lonia to qu is that
primarily for uh employment
opportunities and work for and is that
is that on the North to South Route
people coming in quona to work it's so
it it runs both both ways north to south
south to it is a commuter route so it is
designed for employment opportun unities
uh but anyone can use it it's open to
the general public and we're using
Mid-State Transit and conquered senior
Transit where appropriate as feeders to
the stops for those Po Folks that say
someone lives in Franklin they want to
get to conquer they're not able to do
that get to the bus stop in
Franklin and and they are eligible for
the Mid-State Transit we can use that as
a feeder to the bus stop where they can
catch the uh the conquered lcone
connector
and just a quick follow just a quick
follow up how many trips a day uh four
round trips so four One Direction Four
on the way back gotcha thank you any
further questions I want to thank you
for the work you do and the information
that you provided and if you have
brochures please leave them uh I have
one more card if there's anyone that has
spoken or had not had an opportunity to
speak would like to briefly discuss
things with this committee I urge you to
to pass in a pink card um with that I
recognize representative Edgar from our
own
committee I don't want should do it from
there
Murray
you know how these U phones are I me and
I put the uh put this down I lost the uh
go uh thank you m thank you Mr chair for
allowing me to uh to read this uh this
uh email or it's input from uh
representative uh Kate Murray from uh
Newcastle appreciate this she's uh
pretty sick right now with the flu so
she wasn't able to come in so I
appreciate the opportunity to do this
also got to throw in I appreciate all
the work that uh this this group and do
has done uh uh for the Sea Coast in the
Hampton area thank you
um now now the note from uh from Kate it
is critical that the projects impacting
the safety of Newcastle be included in
the 10-year plan flooding events that
used to be rare are now happening on a
yearly basis indeed more sometimes even
more frequently than once a year both
accesses to the island have been closed
at least twice the season that will only
increase also the seawater flooding the
freshwater marshlands at the low point
on 1B has caused serious flooding of 1B
we realize that the freshwater marshes
will eventually become salt marshes and
people are working on ways to make that
transformation as healthy as possible
the critical element here is that time
has really run out and these flooding
events are becoming the norm this
impacts the safety of everyone who lives
on the island in a very real world
manner please make sure the Newcastle
projects are included in a 10-year
plan I would be again she she mentioned
again that she would be there but she's
sick so again chairman thank you very
much for letting me read this thank you
representative any questions for our
fellow Committee
Member letting them off easy thank
you I appreciate it thank you the uh
that that concludes uh what I have for
cards for
Testimony uh if if there someone had
something new to offer brief that wanted
to speak second time I'd offer you that
opportunity with that we will move
representative I don't know if it's
appropriate but we seem to hear a lot
about Newcastle and the dot is here here
could they we ask them to comment or I
was I was going to ask him as as we go
along during the thank you Mr chairman
yeah
okay um seeing no further I want to
thank our guests for coming forward and
appreciate your time if you have
something else you want to send to
public works for
consideration uh please do so through uh
through the general website uh through
the chairman myself mononi thank you for
your
time
close the public i' would like to close
the public hearing at this
time we used to have a gavel but it's on
the fourth floor right
now thank you so we will uh why don't we
give the members uh five minutes and
then we will uh pick up with do so we'll
be in recess for no more than five
minutes just a point of order Mr
chairman yes sir is it possible to ask
if there's somebody from the
municipality of new Castle here I know
we've heard from citizens is there
anybody that's directly from the
municipality here I I don't believe
there is is there's someone here from
the
you thank you you can just leave right
you
okay a couple of our members had to
testify in other uh other committees so
I I think we're we're back in full force
so I'd like to continue on with the
commissioner you wouldn't mind coming
forward and we will uh take some
questions of the committee of the
commissioner um and um I guess perhaps
you could uh give us an overview of uh
there were several people with concerns
of Newcastle and Ry and so forth for um
and I know you had a a private
conversation could you just update us
where we are with that project sure um
uh once again for the record Bill Cass
commissioner of the do um and I'd also
just give some some some if if I could
to I'd offer I'd also offer some context
on the um on on on the discussion and
several of the comments on the on the
CAC and the EV type of uh application
so excuse me so on um
on Newcastle uh I was pleased to hear
the the the gentleman say that he
thought that the department had been uh
responsive to this so um there were some
2018 19 about concerns with the with the
um with the with the causeway we had
done a we had done a betterman project
uh a few years before that to um redo
the guard rail and uh and restriped the
road and um I think we restriped it n to
get a to get like a one or TW foot uh um
um shoulder on there but as a result of
that uh activity and that work there
were questions raised about the
long-term future of of the uh of the
causeway and what what any future plans
were we really hadn't had any future
plans but um through um you know through
through some discussion I get who the
State Rep is we did um commit to doing a
feasibility study uh we commenced that
in around
2019 um and uh it got a little way laid
through um through through covid but uh
we finished it in um 201 2012 and
started some discussions with with the
town here here were here were the
results and there's and that feasibility
study was fairly high level fairly
conceptual it wasn't a detailed
preliminary design but at least kind of
you know figuring out a general scope of
what what should be um considered and
and taking in additional data for sea
level rise and things like that so A
clarification Please Mr chairman yes
commissioner Cass you said 2019 and you
completed it in 2012 two I'm sorry 2022
if I said 2012 I apologize I'm talking
too fast but uh it got a little like I
said it got a little waye during Co
um but we completed it in 2022 started
some dialogue with the um with the with
the town on that and they had referenced
it it
was it was uh kind of a
um just a a a weird turn of events that
is
that we had we had finished the
feasibility study we had a public
informational meeting out there with the
board of Selectmen at like the end of
November
and that December right before Christmas
there was a there was a nor Easter that
that that that that did overtop the
causeway and it really got um it really
got people stirred up that uh you know
we had a feasibility study and we're
talking about it's not in the 10-year
plan it needs to be added to the 10-year
plan if anything was going to happen so
that it' be you know 10 or more years
before anything is is is done um and the
urgency with that Norm you know got a
lot of discussion with that so through
the uh early part of the 10year plan
development we did uh recognize that and
councilor Stevens had several meetings
out there with constituents so we
included it um in the 10-year plan in
the draft 10-year plan at the end of the
10-year plan so that at least um uh
there is a project there to uh address
the causeway the feasibility study
talked about a three-foot rod of uh
raising the gr raising the um elevation
of the Causeway by 3 feet um to uh take
into account future sea level rise on a
on a medium median
assumption um so that's that's that's
where that's where it stands um so we
did the feasibility study uh kind of
took immediate action with all that all
that feedback and through through the
gasa process of including a project the
10-year plan it's at the end of the
10-year plan um and with some of the
other urgency and discussions through
the gaset process I think we moved the
engineering up by a few years to start
uh to start the
engineering um 2025 or something like
that 26 yeah so started earlier uh so
that we had a detailed design and uh you
know additional discretionary grants or
things should should we could go after
so um I think we did take immediate
action uh it it it is it is an issue
there are a lot of there are a lot of
issues and needs out out there but um
yeah it's it's moving forward but at the
same time uh I know the town and and us
are are looking at in consideration of
discretionary grants if any additional
funding any grant funding can be secured
we could possibly get it done sooner and
move it up um
um thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question is your feasibility
study and other uh
information open transparent and does
the town of Newcastle have a copy of
that yes they do thank you yes it is y y
there several public meetings with them
um because of the level of interest uh
councelor Stevens had asked us to kind
of keep the record open so we continued
receiving um uh feedback and letters of
support uh for for the project
throughout the throughout the throughout
the uh 10e plan development and gaset
hearing process so yeah it's been very
open I think thank you thank you
represent Newton um yes please represent
balong thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again for coming back and take
questions so this isn't a problem just
for Newcastle this is a problem for the
whole SE Co so what what's do doing in
regards to feasibility studies for the
whole for the whole stretch because I
was in I was in Ry about a month ago and
uh picking my way through the rocks and
watching the BMS that were washed away
but I don't see anything for ride down
here but I'm saying that's Ry and you
got North I mean basically you know you
got all the towns right right along
there so it's not a an isolated problem
so uh can you try to get ahead of that
or whatever it is that you're that can
be done to sort of look at it to plan
for uh a a
major approach to Transportation along
the SE coast
and um there are a couple I'll try to be
succinct in my answer to that there are
there are uh several initiatives kind of
going on in in the seast some with the
regional Planning Commission looking at
hazards and risks uh in conjunction with
uh UNH and the coastal risks and and
Hazard committee that continues to to
meet and and bet things so
um we aren't as prominent in that we sit
at the table we're we're a member of of
that but it uh but that's that's a
broader look at the um um not only state
roads but but but town roads land use
planning uh you know some of the
inundation maps and stuff and uh how how
to deal deal with with that so that's
one aspect on the more immediate aspect
and again it's been highlighted by
recent storms on the Sea Coast um the
the uh seaw wall the revetment wall um
along Route 1A particularly from yeah
Hampton Northampton all the way up to
like odion's point and Ry um over over
over the last several years through a
number of nor easers and and and and and
storms has um has uh has taken a uh has
Tak has been battered and and um every
storm weakens it a little bit more and
washes away some more of more of the
stuff so there was a major storm in
2018 um that um had uh a lot of impacts
along the Sea Coast in 1A and as a
result of that storm working through um
working through FEMA and uh you know
some of the um uh emergency relief uh
things through that we embarked we had
started looking at um what it what it
would take to restore the revetment wall
on the seaw wall along there um that's
been in process with various studies for
um several years since since since
2018 and we have developed a uh pretty
comprehensive um um uh preliminary
design of what it would take to rebuild
that seaw wall that revetment wall to
the standards that it was built that
originally following the um the um
Blizzard of 78 was when it was first
built so it's been there for 40 40 plus
years taking a beating so um and we have
been in the process of pursuing um FEMA
funding to to do that there is a project
in the 10-year plan to to address that
um it's the uh Northampton Rye 42 312
project it's on page 160 for for
oh yeah so there are several projects uh
with in in in areas with that so and
it's become and and and the biggest
challenge is cost it's it's a very
expensive project um all told to to do
the whole thing and we've got priority
areas but the whole area would be um
upwards of upwards of $75 million to to
rebuild that so we do
have we talked earlier about the
discretionary Grant we do have a uh
Grant application in uh for a um uh for
$20 million Grant to help do the first
segment the the highest priority segment
we're waiting to hear on that uh again
those discretionary grants are very
competitive and it's very hard to to to
bank on so um I'm rambling a little bit
but we do have a plan we have identified
what what needs to be done uh securing
the funding uh is is a is a real
challenge um whether
um uh you know whether FEMA funds will
will come through we continue to work
through uh Homeland Security and and
with with FEMA um to secure to to see if
there would be funding for that there
are Grant applications at some point if
none of that comes through we may be
looking at using federal funds as part
of the um 10 year plan in future
considerations against all the other
needs
so thank you Mr chair and thanks and I
didn't think it was rambling I thought
you really provided a lot of context it
was good felt likeing very informative
to me and I I appreciate that so um I
just want to say that it does seem like
you've got you've got a seat at the
table for the big picture working with
the planning commissions and with the
the coastal I didn't I didn't get that
organization so somebody's taking that
that big View of like how to address
this because it's a whole East Coast
problem yes that we're we're addressing
um and and I just now see that we've got
all these projects are in for for Ryan
for Northampton so sounds like you're on
the ball so yes appreciate it thanks
thank you thank you before and I'll come
back to you before we finish up on on
this subject um and some members not be
aware I
remember uh this conversation of rising
sea and so forth and uh Hampton and
other roads uh you know worries of of
being torn out um has anyone gone back
and this been going
on a lot of years has anyone gone back
to look at your initial assessments and
seeing if if that is a true course going
forward or are you seeing a deviation
has anybody looked backwards I'm I'm not
sure I follow you but by looking
backwards so if I remember right going
back 10 plus years there was um there
was a need for more money to study
whether it was through UNH or whatever
uh rising sea levels and what it was
going to do for your department
specifically for roads and these these
items people are talking about coming
across um the uh coastal areas has
anyone gone is that an
ongoing
investigation and can you tell me if
what was thought of 10 years ago is
coming true or is it slowly getting
there and I don't need an answer today
you can respond back another time very
quickly it is it is continuing to make
progress so when you said 10 years ago I
know I I had made reference to the uh
Coastal risks and Hazards committee um
they had done a very comprehensive
report um I think it was around 2018
2019 they were charged with that by the
legislature um that um we refer to uh as
far as you know because there are
various scenarios for you know low
medium high assumptions in terms of sea
level rise and and other things and I
think the science is continuing to be
refined as it as it goes on so we rely
heavily on on on on that work and that
work I think continues to be refined the
castal risk and Hazard committee
continues to meet
regularly um reviewing grant grant
opportunities to um again like I had
talked about doing some of the
inundation studies and things like that
so but I can get you some more
information uh uh if if that would help
USA Today addition nothing major please
uh further questions to the commissioner
I'm I apologize
rep yeah yes this isn't a question my my
assistant I I happen to look on a
Newcastle Causeway and he or she put it
up I'm here very good I mean it recapped
what you said commissioner you mentioned
in there it talks a lot a lot about it
so it was new castle.org I looked up
Causeway and this story came up and
there's even a video at the end so I
into okay um and I recognize uh repr
Jack uh thank you it looks like the only
other thing we got asked about was the
CAC project at Durham uh can you talk a
little it seems like the CAC money is
just plane over
subscribed and if we granted Durham's
wish and gave them $3.5 million we' have
to take it away from something else and
so is there a lot of over over
subscription on the CMAC what's this
what's the situation there so that let
me give you some context on that
so uh as part of the 10year plan process
we usually start the the CAC application
round so that we have applications and
we have um uh thing things um ranked and
scored and have a recommendation to
gaset for which projects to include in
the Tenya plan so this round which which
started it it started probably the
winter before so the winter 22 to
23 my dates right it's 24 now because we
started last spring in Earnest with with
the developing the 10-year plan and
stuff like like that and that's when we
had scored an initi ranked uh you know
the the list of applications we got
um so there were there were there were
two primary uh flavors of projects that
that came as part of those applications
and we categorized them into um EV and
non so the EV charging infrastructure
and things like that was a re relatively
new eligibility category with with CMAC
and I think close to 50% of the
applications we got got maybe somewhat
somewhat less I think roughly around 40%
of the applications we had got were for
were for EV charging type of
infrastructure the other 60% were for um
you know non-ev type of work
um transit buses uh sidewalks multi-used
path things like that so um the at the
same time the uh Federal Highway was
developing the um criteria for for EV
charging and and and the final criteria
and details of what would be
required did not come out until May of
last year so may of
2023 so we we took all of the EV related
CMAC projects and kind of put them in
the parking lot for the time being to
see about the eligibility requirements
and and exactly what was going to come
out from Federal Highway um so
um and I think that was part of the
discussion you heard someone from Derry
talk today there was their initial
application when we got the Federal
Highway criteria their initial
application did not fit that criteria so
it wouldn't have been eligible through
some dialogue we went back to them you
know they were modifying their
application to try to meet the um to
meet the criteria um so that that
process went on and and in the list
there were there were several um there
were several EV charging projects that
that didn't meet the the federal
criteria so so we put them off to the
side that they weren't eligible so
through the gaset process at the end of
the gaset process we had made the
recommendation through through GID or
gaset had made the recommendation to
include all of the all of the all of the
eligible CMAC um
applications so when I talk about the
the EV versus
non the in terms of the program being
over subscribed we had uh we had enough
funding identified for all of the non
non EV projects so that was relatively
easy um I think we were when when you
included all of the EV charging projects
we were
probably five or6 million do over
subscribed out of a out of a budget of
roughly $40 million um
so the recommendation that gasset made
and that we have subscribed to is that
even being a little over subscribed we
could probably find a way to to to fund
all those and and work them in either
either through CMAC funds or you or
maybe tapping into some additional funds
uh Bill had mentioned some of the other
Federal programs that were um that had
come out like the carbon Reduction
Program that we could possibly tap some
of those funds to fully fund those
so
um so there are eligibility questions
that need to be worked through they're
fairly stringent um eligibility
requirements for Federal Highway they
want um if you're within a mile of of of
a of alternative fuel Corridor you need
to provide
four DC fast Chargers um uh outside of
that that can be a little bit less but
those were typically more stringent
requirements than some of the
communities had in their applications so
we were working through that um and I
should point out that uh you know so
there's that
Dynamic the governor's office also had
some concerns about the amount of
funding that was going to EV EV charging
and some of the changes in that change
log that came from the governor's office
to the to the to the legisl to the
legislature to house public Public Works
um there were a few of the uh more
costly EV charging projects that the
that the governor's office had uh opted
not to support because they were they
were the more costly and I do think
there was a feeling that there was um uh
a lot of um CMAC funding going to the EV
um category of work um so their their
their their recommended change was to uh
not support a couple of those more
expensive um
um CMAC projects and redirect that money
to um some of the Community
Transportation and uh rail trail
projects and and those are identified in
the change log so UNH was here talking
about their their project um that was
that was one of the higher um higher
cost projects and I think when when when
you look at the list of projects that
one did stick out because it was fairly
expensive so and it's a choice I think
of of of uh you know how how we how we
balance how we balance those funds and
balance those Investments
so thank you and and um before I go to
represent pulner so on on the CMAC and
and trying to U fund aging Rolling Stock
buses and so forth uh what What's the
typical makeup what what's powering
those buses that are going down the road
I would suspect we're not
funding many EV buses at this point in
time with State matched money would I be
correct or
incorrect um I I think you'd be correct
you have anything to ask there's a
single Andre barer is the Deputy
Commissioner of you think there's one
project yeah right that and sure and
then to follow up on that what is what
is the favored propulsion is it are we
natural gas or not using natural gas and
is it diesel there there are several
options Mr chairman um the one I
wouldn't say it's a correction uh but a
I guess a perception that may have been
left with the committee is that CMAC is
is the unique funding source for the
replacement of Rolling Stock and and we
have other programs so 53 39 um they
actually um UNH already has an
application in uh one of the more
traditional programs where we replace
Rolling Stock for all of our Transit
providers using State badge federal
funds so if this is not funded via CMAC
it's not the end of the road for for
their buses I wasn't worried about yeah
right uh there was a mix there was a mix
um uh Coast uh actually we're we've had
a lot of conversations with them about
future transition to other alternate
fuels um uh liquid hydrogen being one
but natural gas regular diesel fairly
typical um of note uh many Transit
providers um outside of our state and
some in our state are also looking at uh
smaller Transit bus options number one
because the availability of those buses
supply chain problems we've had since
the pandemic but also the The Limited
availability of CDL Drivers um frankly
that's a nation wide issue and many
Transit providers are opting for non CDL
required vehicles um as they replace
their larger buses makes
sense if I could ask another question
the um I was surprised in the work that
several of us are on the commission on
how to find out alternate funding for um
for our
roads um that um when we ask for the
percentage of um vehicles was being
powered by natural gas it looks like
there was a curve that went up and that
it's leveled out and are you seeing in
the transit side of things that that's
not attractive and in 10 seconds can you
tell me why it's not attractive well I
yeah Mr chairman I I I wouldn't say it's
not attractive I think there are
definitely Trends in the industry um
there's there's a concerted push for
electrification that's really led by um
California Cali kind of sets the tone
for a lot of Manufacturers because
they're the biggest market for these
buses um I think in this committee we've
identified some of the difficulties and
the issues with range especially in the
Northeast especially in the Northern
Tier of the country uh while
California's jumping in Whole Hog with
electrification um we have very real
range concerns and not to mention the
other concerns with safety um that all
states are dealing with And discussing
so um these are ongoing discussions um
with the um ashto Transit committee it's
our uh trade Association uh of All State
uh Highway Transportation departments so
um yeah it's it's a very real concern I
would say it's not trendy at the moment
there's no particular reason why it it's
not useful as a as a viable fuel source
it is okay thank you represent pulner do
you have question just a CAC was a
program created 4 you 50 years ago
originally to address you know those two
things
congestion and uh air
quality is there a requirement to get
those funds that you show them these are
the most effective cost effective in
terms of either reducing congestion or
improving air quality or do we use use
this kind of as
a as another funding source that you
know equivalent to all the others that
I'm just saying is there a federal
standard we have to meet
to to use the
you know anymore I mean I I I had
alluded to the fact that there are
eligibility requirements for for semac
funding yes um part of the CAC uh
application process is a calculation of
um air quality benefits or or um nox or
greenhouse gas emissions reductions as a
result of of the proposed project um
that is part of the um eligibility
requirements it's also part of the
scoring process when we um when we rank
uh project applications for for funding
um so yeah and I to representative
Jack's question I think you know past
past years there has been um you know
more more projects than there was
funding so that um that air quality
benefit became an even even even more
important category um this this this
round uh there was again the the the
needs pretty closely matched the um
funding so it wasn't as um you know you
still have to meet the eligibility but
um it wasn't as critical a look at the
at the benefits if that makes sense yeah
thank you further questions yes please
rep Newman yes excuse me I'm sorry maybe
just for my benefit I didn't understand
when you said the range considerations
on EVS is that range in distance like
California is huge your hand yeah that's
right um thank you for the question
so range per charge so uh typically what
you heard during testimony is uh that
UNH testified to this and this is the
standard practice is you recharge during
non- peak hours typically so that's
usually overnight with the transit bus
um how many miles you get off a typical
battery charge is the issue so some uh
transit systems uh are relatively
geographically contained small you know
they'll do a lot of runs in a relatively
small area radius Wise from its station
uh some are a little larger um I think
the assessment by Rad's team at Coast
several other of our Transit providers
is battery uh storage especially during
winter months because you get less range
in Colder Weather um isn't there uh for
for most of our transit systems I think
UNH is a little unique um that that may
be there could be a case for that um
there's other pluses for electric buses
they typically um have fewer maintenance
concerns there's few moving Parts in an
electric vehicle but range is the
typical issue that we have here in the
northeas OR in Colder Weather States
thank you thank you for the explanations
further further questions yes um
represent
abbit yes um we have a been provided a
letter from the Town Administrator and
Durham about why their application for
um CAC um was rejected because it
included um
four direct current fast charging
stations and what my question is is is
this a consideration now that they but
it he also says direct current fast
charges while appropriate for short term
Highway fueling stops are extremely
expensive and unnecessary for the sort
of destination charging envisioned in
our original request is
so I mean I'm I'm sure they were aware
of this but it was after the fact after
they had already put the application
in and I mean I guess what I'm asking is
in terms of notification of these rule
changes so as the commissioner said the
rules sort of changed or came out after
the applications were due and one of the
one of the rules and I think we went
over it a little
bit apology um first rule was that
um you had to put in four fast charging
stations um if you were within a mile of
an alternative root Corridor and Durham
Falls half the campus Falls within a
mile of Route four which is an
alternative fuel site uh Corridor um the
other rule is if you're outside that
mile you either have to put in four fast
Chargers or level two charg Chargers
which is slower charger easier less
expensive uh to get and the issue became
where they were going to put them and
they didn't really explain where they
were going to put them um so if if we
can work with them and they say we we'll
put them outside that mile meet the
requirement that's that's great the
other component is they have to be
publicly accessible 247
and in the application and in their
follow-up letter they said that they
would be used
for uh for staff for students and for
visitors so so our concern is are they
publicly accessible do you need a UNH
parking permit to park in that lot um
you know one of the locations was a
commuter lot which was UNH students only
so they I think we can work through that
but the information we had didn't didn't
really address the eligibility
requirements and I think that was our
concern and that was a concern with a
number of um the ones that were were
rejected outright is they didn't meet
that
eligibility thank you further questions
on CMAC before we move on to other R do
you have a question please go right
ahead thank you Mr chair um back to the
C
well um you guys plan on rebuilding it
do you guys plan on rebuilding it the
same height or higher because like last
month or the month before Hampton was
underwater so that I'd like to know that
yeah so we we've established uh you know
and and and through some of that
coordination with with FEMA as the uh as
the um
existing threshold is's the existing
condition to rebuild back to as uh as as
the uh as the walls and their invetment
that were built uh and we have the plans
from um in 1978 following the blizzard
of of 78 so that's kind of the threshold
that's the Baseline that that we're that
we're working to um so that that that
would kind of generate that
would that would set the the basically
the height as the existing height we
would you know part of the engineering
and and some of the
um um hydrodynamic modeling and stuff
have been looking at a a a um at a
better better revetment design that
would hopefully be more efficient and
and more
um uh and and and be able to dissipate
the energy better and things things like
that so um and I would just so be short
answer it's going to be the same height
that revetment wall and seaw wall is is
really you know intended to dissipate
the energy and and and protect the
structures and protect the um um the
road and the Inland um
properties uh it's not necessarily A
containment wall like a dyke that would
that would hold back hold back a higher
level of of water um in those storms and
stuff today A lot of times the the the
waves and stuff are are crashing over
over the seaw wall the problem now is
that the the wall has been battered and
it's so porous that um that it's that
it's letting a lot more energy and a lot
more damage through and I think a lot of
the inundation at least that I've heard
and observed in Hampton and stuff is not
is it's it's as much coming from the
marsh and coming from from from from
behind and and you probably know better
represented that than than than the seaw
wall side it's it's back behind uh
Hampton Harbor in 236 the Sea Level
Rides and the inundation is coming like
from from from the back of the strip and
stuff I think is what we've observed and
I think has been observed So yeah thank
you could I please could I go back to a
previous question it's about Coastal
resilience I please it was actually your
question and to sort of augment or
supplement some of the things the
commissioner said what are we doing with
about to our infrastructure about the
flooding and we talked about um the the
legislative group the coastal risk
Hazard group so they working with UNH
created basically a a bimetric model um
if you put in future year and you put in
you know estimated flood stage it it
shows an inundation model we have we
have a committee at the dot climate
change committee where we meet uh
regularly um to discuss this and talk
about you know if if you see this much
change uh what what infrastructure is
affected and looking at you know how to
address how to be proactive in uh
developing a plan of if if the numbers
do come true you know this bridge is
going to be underwater this roadway is
going to be underwater what do we do
about it how how you know what has to be
done
um and as part of that we talked about
the numbers being updated um by I think
legislation those those numbers the the
model has to be updated every five years
and I know they're in the process of
updating that now um to to to to make
sure that their predictions are are
match reality so we we are working on
that and we we do take it pretty
seriously um but um so I just wanted to
offer that up thank you could I um
represent Mouse I I just had one
hopefully close to final thing before
we're done today and that was just to
get do you have time to give us a a
little mini overview for the people who
haven't been on this committee a long
time you will be coming forth with a
final Amendment for us with little
tweaks and things is is that true
commissioner yes yeah TP typically in in
addition to the to the book there is uh
kind a narrative or or or or or language
written in in in the bill that would
detail um any of the any of the any of
the changes and and stuff so that there
is a um I guess kind of a written record
to go along with whatever the changes
are in the book so one of the things we
had referenced was um uh and we're in
the process of doing that the the the
fact that you know this 10-year plan is
based on a snapshot that we took last
summer we need to reconcile it with any
changes that have have happened since
then we would look at those as kind of
administrative changes but um we would
want to capture those in such an uh uh
in such an an amendment or in the um
HB 2024 language yeah yeah so we are we
are scheduled to meet again on the
21st and we'll be working on the 23rd
but we are looking at be executing this
bill on the 23rd do you see that's going
to be enough time for your department to
be able to come up with those changes or
are we looking further out I I'd like to
work with you so we had an
idea yeah we'll we'll try to achieve
that okay and if there's any savings
that have been found we'd like to hear
them before the Senate hears
it we might get a project representative
Jack yeah just following up on
representative Mills there's always
there seems to be always some little
tweak that has to be made to turnpikes
to adjust the numb slightly and that's
part of what gets put into the committee
Amendment so I hope you won't forget to
do that right yeah and hopefully there
aren't too too too many tweaks this time
I know we had talked about um you know
uh the um Assumption of of some some um
bonding utilization to keep some
projects some turny capital projects on
track that
uh that bonding limitation is already in
the LI limit is already in the
legislation so um we're not seeking
additional just uh we haven't we haven't
utilized all of that authority to to
date so um but we can C so that might
something like that may not wouldn't
wouldn't in my mind require a a change
in the language but we will make sure we
take a look at that so and and and again
I know the the several things I think on
the 21st we'll come prepared to talk
about red lless Bridges um about the um
Boston express service and and the i93
and at the ever Corridor um um it's been
late I could probably answer some some
questions on um on the capital court or
come back at the next meeting to to do
that with regard to representative
Jack's questions and um any of the other
testimony that you heard today that we
want to speak to we can um address that
as well okay I I appreciate that I have
a couple more um so the Sea Coast isn't
the only U population that's had issues
challenging the storms and so forth
North North Country uh Madison Tamworth
oy
Wakefield um we had two or three
tremendous
events um and I was very pleased with
the Department's response I was very
pleased that the commissioner and others
took time uh in my disbelief of how much
uh uh damage Financial damage we had on
our roads uh learning that there were
different pots of money that you're
working with so I I really appreciate
all that help my my question is tell me
about
FEMA um I know that a town in particular
oapi was lucky enough to have a former
employee of yours MH who was who was
very very tuned in to software and
knowledge and knowing what FEMA
wanted so that they had a they were very
hard hit they had over a million dollars
worth of damage but they were they were
able to capture that document and put it
in the form def FEMA by software I
believe that that town has already
received their funding back to them uh
and many of my other towns are not so
lucky and I asked uh um ma Senator
Hassen to uh if we could get to a point
that we could
share that software to our towns instead
of towns having to purchase it I guess
Mike could could you help me understand
a little better um and I would hope that
the department was quick in receiving
funds as quick as FEMA could be that's a
good way to put it as quick as FEMA can
be because feema FEMA's words were you
have this damage you need to take care
of your damage and we'll catch up with
you in a year and we'll see what what's
eligible to be paid for and we'll get
that allotment is is there a is there a
a femous software package that uh that's
being used by the state for this
purpose um or are you folks pulling out
books and copying
pages are you are you if I may yeah
please
please for the record my name is David
rodrig assistant commissioner to to my
knowledge we don't use a specific
software but we do use a specific
process to go out and mark the
locations and collect the the evidence
of the damage before we fix it and then
very carefully um take care of the qu
quantities of materials and equipment
and effort that goes into repairing each
specific location so I will check on the
software I'm not aware of a of a
software it is more the process I will
tell you we have six districts we have
multiple um people that do this the FEMA
rules continuously change every storm it
seems there's a different set of rules
that that we are work working from and
even within the do we have pockets of
excellence and this gentleman or
gentlewoman from oap was one of those
pockets of Excellence we also have
districts and places that struggle a
little bit more ourselves um collecting
the the right information and evidence
and really comes down to breaking up the
locations into small discret locations
that that FEA requires us to report by
thank you I I look forward to hearing
what you have to say and I don't know if
after that Discovery and maybe we'll
pick it up when this reaches the Senate
but perhaps we should think of some
Outreach that the department can do with
the towns uh there was some legislation
to create a fund and we're going to
consider that going forward but it just
it just for those that aren't aware and
you haven't had this tragedy befall your
town
so I have um I have a piece of um road
that was washed out the width of that
building and FEMA will come out and
they'll want to know what it was before
before the day it happened and it's a
reasonable plan that there you want to
restore that road that length to the
condition it was Prior but you you you
need to go so much more Beyond how many
yards of gravel you used what type of
gravel you used what type of vehicle you
used you can't just say a six-wheeler
they got to know what the manufacturer
of that six-wheeler was they need to
know how many drivers were in it they
need to know what grade pay your driver
was at they need to know where the
material went that you took away when it
came back how much time if you used a
compactor on that what size compactor
was it it is an
enormously difficult process that many
any of the small towns just throw up
their hands and their budgets go to heck
so I'm I'm still pressuring U the
senator to see what we could do I would
sincerely appreciate I know you have a
load of work that's unbelievable but I
think if we could do that Outreach
somehow and if some funding was needed
for that uh if it could be brought
forward to us uh food for thought and
and and with that representative that I
mean getting back to the beginning of
the question there we can also do a
quick briefing I mean we have several uh
emergency repair projects as a result of
some of the storm damage you're familiar
with the one in um Madison and stuff um
so we can give you a quick briefing on
those I don't believe I'll have to
double check it because they're more
immediate and they don't fall in the 25
through 34 time frame they probably
storm um repair uh permanent repair
projects that that may not be reflected
in the 10-year plan anyway so that might
be one of the um updates we can provide
as well too thank you and I I but I I
really want you to think about and find
out if there there is
that you're the experts many of the
towns don't have people in place for
that so I think if we could be a little
more proactive I think it'd be wonderful
other questions to the commiss yes yes I
represent yeah I just have a comment I
hardly concur the chair's comments about
flooding because in my uh Sullivan
County area we've had some severe
selling in one of my towns Cen and in
aworth and I think also in Cheshire
county there's been some problem so we
really these small communities it over
swamps their Road budgets and they've
got to repair them and they just can't
afford it so these small communities
really need help so whatever and I think
you have tried to help but they you know
whatever we can work with you to get
more more funding and to get FEMA to
respond more quickly and reimburse these
communities that's you know part of the
problem that I'm hearing thank you thank
you was
rep thank you Mr chairman um trying to
wrap my head around everything that's
been going on here today and this just
the way my mind works so bear with me
we've all everybody here has projects on
this 10-year plan in their
Community I'm realizing the extent of
what has to happen to make these
projects
work what do I tell my constituents if
they have a concern let's say in
Rochester the tiets Road intersection
that's on the 10-year plan
realistically what is the percentage of
projects that are on the 10-year plan
that get done in 10 years and that get
replaced by other things and never get
done cuz I'd like to be able to tell my
constituents well well it's on the
10-year plan but it doesn't necessarily
mean it's going to get done unless this
falls into place this falls into place
that's what it seems like I'm hearing
today that you have a plan but it
doesn't mean it's going to
happen well hopefully we we're we're
we're doing a much better job than in
than in than in years past I think you
know
historically um and and some of the
members have been here for a long time
remember when we had a very over
programmed 10-year plan where the
10-year plan was estimated to take 35
years to complete all the projects in
that and um um you know it it set up
false expectations like you're like
you're
describing a lot of Mr renberg's
discussion this morning with regard to
inflation and uh some of the charts and
the money in and money out is is all
based on I think actions that this
committee has had had taken within the
last eight eight or 10 years where where
where adopted the um and altered or
clarified I guess the law to require us
to provide a financially constrained
10year plan that takes into account
inflation and budgets projects based on
the year of construction costs
so before that uh we we we weren't as
diligent in doing that and it led to a
lot of the um Mis Mis expectations that
you reference
so hopefully we're doing a a a better
job in in doing that our goal would be
that if a project gets established in
the 10-year plan unless the priorities
change by the by the region or something
that um it will be um it will work
through the process and it will be
delivered in the time frame that uh that
is reflected here I'm not sure I'm not
familiar with the Rochester tbit Road
Project um there are many things that
affect a project delivery whether it be
permitting whether it be public support
public
consensus um things like that but
um
um I think you tell your constituents
that that the particularly with the work
that the committee has has done to
require us to do a a financially
constrained 10year plan that effect that
that it takes into account and inflation
that that uh this is a um much more
dependable doc and if there is a uh
Community project that is in the 10e
plan that it will be delivered in the in
the time um that's indicated
here so further questions we will have
an opportunity to sit again on the
21 uh but we're going to start narrowing
down pretty much so that we can uh get
ourselves in a position uh to bring out
a final a final report on the
23rd um so
if there's further questions that you
need answered from the commissioner or
the the staff please forward them
through myself we'll make sure that they
um with that I I do you have anything
else you'd like to discuss at this time
you find any money while we were sitting
here no I I gu I I just uh one more one
one more thought to uh representative
Newton's question uh for example so we
have been relatively fortunate with the
with the federal funding and stuff two
years ago when the iiga was passed we
got uh a a a a pretty good increase in
in federal funding which drives a lot of
our our program um inflation has has um
uh taken up a lot of that so that we're
not with that additional funding we we
we found that we haven't been able to do
a lot of new and additional work but but
the existing work that's in there um is
is is sustainable and and keeping on
that's on the federal side we talked
about some potential Del delays on the
on the turnpike side and that again is
directly driven by um by by revenue
streams and stuff like that so we have
you know we have costs going up Revenue
staying
flat and as a result you know things
things move out move things have to move
out or or delay
um so every two years we update that and
provide that that explanation and and
and what the choices are to the to the
committee and stuff like that but um
particularly on the turnpike side that's
just kind of the nature of things you
know we have increasing cost level
Revenue
so you know Pro projects projects end up
delaying or
sliding so I I you know I don't know if
that's a Miss we try our best to explain
those those constraints and stuff but um
it it is kind of a fact of life if if if
it's important that that those projects
or those communities uh you know that
those projects be kept on on track um we
we need to find a way to compensate for
the for the um increasing cost so yes so
so thank you for that so the same thing
that's happening to all of us is
happening to you too yes thank you
you're welcome um one one last item if I
could leave you with and perhaps next
week you could give me a matrix so we
have had in the last couple years and
we've had it for years towns will not be
or cities will not be happy with the
10-year plan process and they'll come in
and they will they will want to uh have
this committee legislate a change
um I think of Conway which was last year
which was a lot of work seemed to have
the consensus of the department the
engineers and the town but a certain
amount of citizenry was not in favor of
it we just went through just recently
Salem 111 uh that intersection could you
and and I had a dinner just the other
night and I was inundated by the good
people of
wolfboro uh with the thoughts of two
roundabouts at both ends of their town
and what a crazy idea that
is um could you just give us a quick
matrick and I don't need it today that
says here's how the process starts as a
project it makes its way in it has a
planning process and then talk about the
public process because you're in town
you're making a presentation I assume
with most of these towns you know
there's there's input from their the
from their engineer or their staff
there's a Buy in and then you come back
again and you present the project and so
many times good projects get railed by
three or four people that hadn't heard
what was going on and that creates a
headache for yourselves and it ends up
back here so um just a sheet of bullet
points of how this goes through and I
think it would be helpful for my
committee members and for myself when
I'm having dinner in different towns
that I could I could pull that sheet of
paper out because you folks really do
your due diligence you don't always
adhere to your own plan and take input
and I think it would be helpful if you
could pull that together and I don't
necessarily need that for next week
because you have so much to do but I I
think a simple sheet would be would be
very helpful okay all right we'll work
on that definitely thank you all right
with that um I want to thank you for
your time um we will uh we will be back
here next
21st I don't have the calendar in front
of me unfortunately if if I if I set the
time it's 10 o'clock but please uh
please check the time in the calendar
all right thank you thank you
commissioner directors and all the good
people from
dot um to are there any business any
business be what time was it at 10
o'clock
so is there any no one else has any
other business
uh just to remind we have a session
tomorrow at 1 and I don't know I know
about the Republicans the Democrats have
a caucus and lunch in at at noon time
and I you know but in other words so
don't come in I was thinking of coming
in early we got work to do and I'll come
to an empty room tomorrow so I'm just
trying to not only REM mind you remind
myself if you have extra food let the
Republicans okay all right okay all
right
think